demander de reprendre vos places nos
collègues qui veulent encore discuter
quelques instants avec Madame la
Ministre peuvent rester dehors mais je
voudrais pas que voilà s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît merci donc nous
sommes très heureux d'accueillir pour
cette audition Serge Serge merci s'il
vous
plaît s'il vous plaît on commence voilà
nous sommes donc très heureux
d'accueillir monsieur Luc qui est le PDG
du groupe EDF avant afin d'échanger avec
lui sur le secteur bien sûr de l'énergie
et notamment sur la programmation et la
régulation électrique 1 an après
l'audition préalable que nous avions
déjà mené au sein de notre commission
pour votre nomination en un an les
sujets se sont enchaînés avec les lois
sur la relance de l'énergie nucléaire et
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables désormais en vigueur et
celle sur la programmation et la
régulation énergétique et la sûreté
nucléaire qui sont en attente d'examen
sur le plan réglementaire une nouvelle
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
et un nouveau prix de l'électricité ont
été annoncés dans ce contexte je
souhaiterit recueillir monsieur le
Président Directeur Général votre avis
sur plusieurs sujets qui sont liés à la
relance de l'énergie nucléaire en
premier lieu pouvez-vous nous indiquer
où en est l'instruction de la
construction des PR 2 et du
SMR la construction des 6 PR2 a été
annoncée à pli Graveline et au budget si
l'échéance de 2023 pour le dépôt des
autorisations du premier site a été
respecté celle de 2025 et 2027 le
seront-elles également est-ce qu'il est
nécessaire de convenir de la
construction des h autres PR2 dès 2020
23 dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation énergétique et de la PPE
avez-vous une idée des sites qui sont en
liste pour les accueillir enfin quant au
SMR nuvarde sa mise en service d'ici
2030 est-elle tenable en second lieu
pouvez-vous nous préciser comment
financer la relance de l'énergie
nucléaire EDF doit prendre en charge la
construction des 6 et per2 pour un
montant de 50 milliards d'euros et le
grand carénage pour un montant de 65
milliards d'euros or l'entreprise est
grevée d'une dette de 65 milliards
d'euros sa notation financière étant
BBB plus comment faire plusieurs modèles
de financement existent à l'échelon
européens par des fonds propres par
emprunt par prix régulés ou encore par
participation de consommateurs
électrointensif la Cour des comptes a
indiqué queedf ne peut pas financer seul
ces chantiers qu'en pensez-vous les
contrats pour différence obtenus dans le
cadre de la réforme du marché européen
de l'électricité constitue-t-il les
moyens de financement
idouine ou faut-il envisager d'autres
outils je rappelle que les hypothèses de
garantie d'emprunt d'avance remboursable
voire de mobilisation du livréa ont tour
à tour été évoqué par la presse quant au
dispositifs de l'accès régulé à
l'électricité nucléaire historique
laarenne la mission d'information que
j'ai eu le plaisir de conduire avec
notre collègue Fabien Guay a clairement
rappelé qu'il s'agissait d'un mécanisme
à bout de souffle son prix de 42 € par
MWh apparaît largement obsolète EDF
ayant préconisé une revalorisation de
64,8 € sur la période
2026-2030 contre 60 ,7 € pour la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie
qu'est-ce qui peut expliquer ce
différentiel en 3ème lieu pouvez-vous
nous livrer votre avis sur la future
programmation énergétique nous avons
reçu il y a 15 jours de cela dans cette
enceinte le président de RTE qui nous a
présenté son futur énergétique à
l'horizon 2050 et son bilan prévisionnel
[Musique]
2023-2035 avez-vous une préférence parmi
les mix électriques qui sont proposés
par RTE allant de 100 % d'énergie
renouvelable à 50 % d'énergie nucléaire
enfin en dernier lieu pour ne pas être
trop longue pouvez-vous nous préciser
l'organisation de votre groupe pour
faire face à la relance de l'énergie
nucléaire où en êtes-vous dans les
recrutements nécessaires s'agissant des
6 PR2 EDF a évalué en juillet 2022 les
besoins à 30000 recrutement pour leur
construction et à 10000 pour leur
exploitation jusqu'à 15000 recrutement
aujourd'hui ont été lancés en novembre
2022 où en êtes-vous également de toutes
les réorganisations induites un projet
de réorganisation autour de 5 piliers a
été annoncé en juin 2023 enfin que
pensez-vous de l'écosystème des
entreprises qui sont liées à l'énergie
nucléaire entre le rachat par EDF des
turbines arabelles le REF par l'état de
la session des fabricants de
robinetterie seg et velant ou encore la
mobilisation de parlementaires contre la
session du fabricant de système de
commande contrôle Athos les sujets de
préoccupation sont pour le moins
nombreux voilà quelquesunes des
questions sur lequell bien évidemment
vous allez pouvoir nous répondre et sur
lequel aussi nos collègues vont vous
interroger je donc vous propose d'y
répondre d'ors et déjà et ensuite je
laisserai la parole à l'ensemble de nos
rapporteurs rapporteurs qui sont déjà
intervenus sur un certain nombre de
projets de loi devenu loi ou de projets
de loi à venir
merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs merci beaucoup de de votre
accueil et je suis très heureux d'être
de retour parmi vous après presque un an
dans mes fonctions à la tête de
DF après une année dans lequelle le le
principe qui s'applique à EDF qui est
qu'on ne s'ennuie jamais c'est tout tout
à fait vérifié donc je je vais essayer
madame la Présidente de répondre à vos
questions en en commençant si vous le
permettez par vous donner quelques
nouvelles du court terme parce que chez
edef nous devons évidemment programmer
le long terme mais nous devons faire en
sorte aussi que tout fonctionne à court
terme et le court terme a été fortement
sollicité ces dernières semaines et
comme nous sommes à la veille de l'hiver
je vous vous donnerai également quelques
nouvelles pour l'hiver qui s'annonce le
court terme c'est évidemment les tempête
et notamment la tempête Caram qui a qui
a évidemment très profondément euh
touché notre pays et notamment deux
régions qui sont la Bretagne et la
Normandie puisque 1,2 million de clients
ont été coupés jeudi de novembre au
matin euh 700000 d'entre eux ont été
raccordés dans les 24 heures et à
l'heure où nous parlons 97 % environ des
clients sont raccordés sont à nouveau
reconnectés et évidemment ceci est dû à
une extrêmement forte mobilisation des
équipes d'enedis et de l'ensemble de nos
partenaires industriels et à une
anticipation également de la tempête
puisque D 2 jours avant la tempête nos
équipes sont montées au front je pense
que c'est le terme qui convient de
d'employer avec 3400 collaborateurs
d'énédice et de nos partenaires
industriels qui se sont rendus sur les
zones qui allaient être touchées pour
être à pied d'œuvre au moment où les
dégâts seraient causés de façon quasi
certaine par la tempête nous déplorons
malheureusement la disparition tragique
d'un de nos collaborateurs Frédéric
Despo âgé de 46 ans technicien
d'intervention d'énédis originaire d'Och
qui était venu aider ses collègues en
Bretagne et je veux dire toute la
solidarité du groupe à sa famille euh
voilà pour la tempête il reste
évidemment encore à ce
jour 40000 de nos concitoyens qui ne
sont pas qui ne sont pas à nouveau
reconnectés je veux dire également que
je sais que tous nos collaborateurs ne
prendront du repos que quand tout le
monde sera
reconnecté voilà ça c'est pour le très
court terme ça veut dire
qu'effectivement l'impact climatique est
là et que nous devons continuer de
travailler pour être prêt pour faire
face à ce type d'événement et je crois
que l'anticipation d'énadis était à la
hauteur de ce type d'événement sur sur
le cas de la tempête kan et a permis
aussi de gérer la tempête Domingos qui a
eu un impact moindre mais néanmoins
engendré 160000 clients coupés samedi à
7h du matin euh dont 112000 étaient
rétablis à 18h euh voilà pour les
éléments de la tempête je voudrais vous
dire un mot maintenant de la production
puisque nous abordons l'hiver et euh la
tempête montre que l'hiver peut peut
réserver des surprises euh ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que la mobilisation
extrêmement forte de l'entreprise depuis
euh la découverte du phénomène de
corrosion sous contrainte à la toute fin
de l'année 2021 euh permet d'aborder cet
hiver avec une marge de production qui
est très supérieure à celle de l'année
dernière puisque nous sommes aujourd'hui
modulo quelques éléments qui sont
consécutifs de la tempête et qui ne vont
pas durer à 40 GW de production
disponible pour le mois de novembre euh
nous serons à 45 en décembre et à 50 GW
en janvier c'est-à-dire avec une marge
de productible comme on dit qui est
significative par rapport à l'année
dernière euh nous avons également un
remplissage des retenus hydrauliques qui
est supérieur à la moyenne historique et
donc une capacité de turbinage qui nous
euh permet d'avoir une marge euh plus
confortable beaucoup plus confortable
que l'année précédente ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il faut abandonner les efforts
de sobriété euh nous avons euh euh
réussi euh tous ensemble l'ensemble de
la nation à passer l'hiver dernier en
partie aussi grâce aux efforts de
sobriété qui sont de 8 à 9 %. euh ça
c'est l'énergie qu'on ne consomme pas et
l'énergie qu'on ne consomme pas par
définition c'est la meilleure euh et
donc nous devons euh continuer de
maintenir notre attention collective sur
l'effort de sobriété euh qui euh s'il
n'est pas strictement indispensable d'un
point de vue de sécurité énergétique et
sécurité électrique pour cet hiver
continue de euh nous pousser
collectivement dans la bonne direction
qui est euh la sobriété énergétique au
sens large euh vous m'avez interrogé
madame la Présidente sur euh la relance
du du nucléaire
évidemment nous sommes un moment pivot
un moment charnière de l'histoire du
groupe EDF et de l'histoire de notre
pays
puisque après deux décennies pendant
lesquelles nous avons bénéficié d'un
parc nucléaire installé qui répondait au
besoins du pays sur le plan électrique
nous entrons maintenant dans deux
décennies dans lesquelles nous allons
non seulement devoir péreniser ce parc
mais également faire face à une demande
d'électricité croissante qui doit
trouver sa réponse dans une production
d'électricité décarbonée qui répondent à
l'ensemble des enjeux du pays et qui
soit également capable à terme de
remplacer le parc nucléaire lors qu'il
lorsqu'il aura atteint euh sa sa son
obsolescence ce qui fatalement finira
par arriver un jour et donc cette
période charnière elle doit nous amener
à être capable de mener de fronts euh à
la fois l'investissement qui convient de
faire sur le parc nucléaire existant on
parle d'un ordre de grandeur de 5
milliards d'euros par an pour continuer
de le péréniser en toute sûreté euh de
d'investir sur le réseau électrique et
les événements de la semaine montrent
queil faut continuer d'investir sur le
réseau électrique pas uniquement pour
augmenter sa résilience qui est fait de
façon constante depuis la tempête de 99
mais également pour raccorder davantage
d'énergie renouvelable qui qui vient
compléter le dispositif électrique de
façon ABS abument utile mais qui
nécessite un effort constant sur sur le
raccordement 80 % des raccordements
d'énergie renouvelable sont fait sur le
réseau de distribution et donc c'est un
effort d'investissement qui est
également très important et il nous faut
préparer l'avenir en ayant des moyens de
production commandable décarboné et les
moyens de production commanda décarboné
sont de deux natures dans les
technologies qui sont matures
aujourd'hui qui sont maîtrisables
maîtrisés c'est le nucléaire et
l'hydroélectricité sur le le nucléaire
nous devons
évidemment continuer d'avancer sur le
programme PR2
et nous sommes dans une phase dans
lequelle le programme est en définition
détaillée c'est-à-dire que nous devons
définir l'objet que nous devrons
construire et en parallèle nous
travaillons évidemment avec chacun des
sites qui ont été à ce stade
sélectionnés et annoncés pour évidemment
passer par la phase de consultation du
public qui est absolument indispensable
puis pour rentrer dans une dans les
procédures administratives qui sont
préalables à l'engagement des travaux en
parallèle nous avons un travail
industriel très profond euh sur lequel
nous continuons de mobiliser l'ensemble
de la filière
électronucléaire et ce travail
industriel est destiné à finaliser la
définition de ces epr2 des objets que
nous allons construire et de faire en
sorte que nous optimisions ce ce ce
programme que nous optimisions l'objet à
construire avec un objectif qui est
assez simple c'est d'être les meilleurs
dans sa construction en série donc
l'objectif n'est pas d'être le meilleur
sur le premier qu'on va construire
l'objectif c'est d'avoir défini ce
programme pour que dans la série de
construction nous soyons les meilleurs
nous puissions accélérer la construction
au fur à mesure de leur construction
parce que comme dans toute industrie
c'est quand on en fait beaucoup qu'on
devient meilleur et comme les besoins
seront à terme à hauteur des des besoins
qui sont couverts par le parc plus la
croissance de la demande électrique
c'est bien dans cette faculté de
construire en série dans les meilleures
conditions possibles que nous devons
travailler donc nous entrons dans une
phase d'optimisation de ce programme qui
va tirer tout le parti des travaux qui
sont déjà faits plus de la revue de
maturité du programme qui est en cours
et des recommandations qui sortent de
cette revue de maturité qui a été
évidemment réalisé à la fois par des
personnels intern à EDF mais également
par beaucoup d'experts extérieurs et
avec la participation des services de
l'État et c'est sur la base de ces
recommandations que nous entrons dans
une phase d'optimisation de ce projet
qui va prendre plusieurs mois d'ici
l'été prochain au moins et dans cette
phase d'optimisation notre objectif
c'est de de nous mettre dans les
meilleures conditions pour pouvoir
engager ensuite la phase décisionnelle
la phase de construction voilà pour PR2
pour projet
newward le projet new est dans une phase
qui est encore un peu moins avancée à ce
st
que le projet PR2 pour ce pour ce qui
est de la définition des objets à
construire nous sommes dans une phase de
définition préliminaire euh du projet
newward avec des des connaissances
fortes sur l'ensemble des éléments qui
doivent constituer ce projet de réacteur
et nous souhaitons simplement aller vite
avec une stratégie qui consiste à avoir
un réacteur modulaire facile à
construire et euh et réplicable de façon
simple pour des clients qui seraient en
France en Europe ou dans le monde euh
correspondant à une demande qui est bien
identifiée qui est en général d'ailleurs
euh dans beaucoup de pays euh la faculté
de remplacer une centrale au charbon
exactement sur le même site avec la même
source froide et le même raccordement au
réseau donc c'est c'est c'est exactement
ce type de réacteur qu'il faut pour
remplacer une centrale au charbon et
donc correspondre au besoin de beaucoup
de pays qui souhaitent accélérer leur
décarbonation euh nous ne serons pas
prêt à le mettre en service en 2030 nous
serons prêts à le construire en 2030 euh
pour répondre à votre question
euh je je viens maintenant à vos
questions sur le financement
euh je pense d'une manière générale dans
toute industrie on on peut pas euh
aborder les questions de financement des
des outils industriels euh sans parler
du modèle économique de l'industrie et
nous sommes à ce stade également à une
croisée des chemins sur le modèle
économique de notre industrie euh et
c'est l'ensemble de l'industrie
électrique dont je parle euh nous avons
depuis quelques semaines euh un accord
historique à l'échelle européenne sur
les règles de marché européennes sur le
marché électrique et je pense qu'on peut
qualifier cet accord historique
notamment à deux titres euh le premier
c'est que c'est la première fois depuis
que ce marché européen existe que il y a
un accord clair de l'ensemble des
États-membres sur le fait que notre
marché électrique doit permettre la
formation de prix à long terme et la
formation de prix à long terme est la
meilleure façon pour tout marcher mais
particulièrement applicable à notre
marché
électrique d'obtenir une stabilité et
une visibilité des prix à long terme à
la fois pour les consommateurs et pour
les industriels qui investissent dans la
capacité de production c'est ce qui
manquait principalement à notre marché
électrique depuis sa création et donc
c'est ce premier élément est un un
élément historique de cet accord
européen le deuxième élément qui est
historique c'est que ces règles de
marché sont agnostique sur le plan
technologique c'est-à-dire que il y a un
accord clair sur les règles de marché
qui ne fait pas de différence dès lors
que on vise tous à l'échelle européenne
la décarbonation de l'électricité euh
cet accord ne fait pas de différence
entre les différentes technologie qui
concourent à l'électricité décarboné
donc ces deux éléments sont vraiment des
éléments qui son fondateur je crois d'un
d'une nouvelle approche européenne qui
va nous permettre à l'échelle française
également de réinventer notre modèle
réinventer notre modèle à l'échelle
française ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
pour être capable de financer les
infrastructures du futur être capable de
donner de la visibilité équilibrée entre
les clients les consommateurs qui
souhaite avoir évidemment une
électricité
compétitive une électricité qui qui soit
un prix qui est connu et qui est visible
à l'avance et puis les producteurs et au
premier rang des producteurs EDF qui a
besoin également d'une visibilité
économique pour être capable de se
lancer dans le programme
d'investissement que je viens de décrire
nous y travaillons et nous y travaillons
évidemment main dans la main avec nos
clients et je vais vous dire ici et
remercier d'ailleurs l'intensité des
discussions que nous avons avec les
clients notamment
industriels qui sont à juste titre très
impliqué dans la définition de ce que
sera le futur du marché électrique
français et puis évidemment nos
discussions sont également intense avec
le gouvernement les administrations pour
chercher la meilleure voie possible dans
une discussion qui est parfaitement
équilibré dans laquelle EDF cherche
autant le succès des clients que la
soutenabilité de DF et l'État cherche
autant la soutenabilité de DF que le
succès des clients donc ce travail est
intense il nécessite de repenser notre
modèle donc il nécessite que nous osions
réfléchir différemment parce que les
règles ne sont plus les mêmes et qu'il
nous faut être capable d'élaborer
quelque chose de nouveau dans ce quelque
chose de nouveau nous avons un certain n
d'éléments que
EDF en tant que industriel commerçant
responsable a apporté dans le débat et
ces éléments sont tout ce que le contrat
de long terme permet de faire euh des
contrats à long terme il en existe de
plein de types il en existe déjà euh on
parle
de pardon si j'utilise un un acronyme
anglais horrible mais on parle de
corporate pipier beaucoup dans le
renouvelable un corporate ppier c'est un
contrat de long terme entre un
industriel qui crée une capacité de
production renouvelable et puis une
entreprise qui s'engage à acheter cette
électricité sur le long
terme ce type de contrat peut se
répliquer dans d'autres domaines et fait
partie de la
panoplie de coinvestissement ou de
partenariat industriel que DF souhaite
développer pour donner de la visibilité
à ses partenaires industriel sur le long
terme y compris à partir de la capacité
de production nucléaire le deuxième
élément c'est que il nous faut être
capable de tirer l'ensemble de notre
marché électrique vers le long terme et
c'est la raison pour laquelle le DF a
pris l'initiative il y a plusieurs mois
d'aller vers la
création d'un
produit côté sur le long terme sur le
marché électrique qui permet de donner
des prix pour 2027 et 2028 accessibl à
nos concurrents aussi c'est-à-dire que
nous sommes prêts à vendre de
l'électricité à nos concurrents sur ces
horizons de temps et les prix qui
sortent sur ce marché de long terme sont
aujourd'hui autour de 77 € du MWh pour
l'année 2028 et autour du 83 85 selon
les jours pour 2027 euh c'estàd qu'on
est plus du tout à cet horizon de temps
euh la formation d'un prix normal n'est
plus du tout dans les prix de guerre on
est revenu dans un atterrissage
normal des prix de l'électricité à cet
horizon de temps le fait d'avoir pris
cette initiative nous permet aujourd'hui
de commencer à aborder nos clients
puisque nos concurrents peuvent se
sourcer dans les mêmes conditions que DF
le fait d'avoir pris ces initiativ nous
permet d'aborder nos clients en ayant
une discussion avec nos clients qui
n'est pas limité à la vente
d'électricité pour l'année prochaine ou
pour l'année suivante mais qui permet
dans envisager d'emblé un horizon de
long terme par définition beaucoup moins
susceptible d'être affecté par la
volatilité que les structures commercial
que nous avons aujourd'hui voilà les
outils que EDF apporte à la discussion
évidemment ça doit être complété par des
instruments qui permettent au pouvoir
public de garder le contrôle de ce
marché notamment dans les situations
tendues et donc ces discussions là elles
relèvent davantage d'instruments qui
permettent au pouir pouvoir public de
récupérer sur les producteurs et
notamment sur EDF une capacité de
financement et de
redistribution qui serait mise en œuvre
à partir d'un certain nombre de seuil
qui sont en cours de discussion voilà
voilà les outils dont nous parlons
aujourd'hui et j'ai commencé par ça
parce que il est impossible d'avoir une
stratégie de financement si on n pas de
visibilité sur le modèle économique à la
fois pour les clients et pour les
producteurs et donc c'est bien là-dessus
qu'il faut se focaliser en premier une
fois qu'on a cette visibilité
naturellement les outils que vous avez
cité sont des outils qui peuvent être
appelés dans la stratégie de financement
pour l'instant il y a encore beaucoup de
travail à faire donc je ne peux pas vous
vous donner des éléments de certitude à
ce stade sur les modèles de financement
qui seront appelés pour le nouveau
nucléaire les éléments simplement que je
peux vous donner c'est que à ce stade le
groupe EDF n'aura pas les capacités de
financer seul ces objets pour tout un
tas de raisons la première c'est que
dans le mondeélectrique d'aujourd'hui
aucun investissement ne se fait fait
sans une forme de soutien public
aucun donc si edef pouvait y arriver
tout seul ça serait une sorte de miracle
mais malheureusement nous n'avons pas
les conditions de créer le miracle donc
donc il faut une forme de de garantie ou
une forme de soutien public qui est
notamment destiné à
compenser l'absence de profondeur
financière qui existe quand on doit
aborder un programme de l'ampleur dont
on parle
euh les marchés financiers n n'ont
aujourd'hui pas la capacité de de
regarder un acteur futile public en
disant ok nous allons sur la seule base
des marchés financiers prendre des
volumes de financement aussi
considérables sans qu'une sans qu'une
forme de garantie ou une forme de
soutien public ne soit affirmé je peux
pas vous donner les paramètres à ce
stade ni les instruments qui seront son
utiles il y en a beaucoup
euh nous les examinons nous sommes en
train de travailler dessus avec
évidemment les administrations et le
gouvernement mais dès lors que nous
aurons un modèle économique qui est qui
donne de la visibilité nous pourrons
accélérer ce travail là donc voilà où
nous en sommes sur la partie financement
euh sur le futur euh euh pardon je je je
je termine juste d'un mot sur la
structure du marché naturellement la
structure du marché
maintient dans le futur un tarif
réglementé de vente pour pour les
clients celui-ci n'est pas changé
d'ailleurs par les les nouvelles règles
du de marché européenne et donc pour les
clientèles qui sont non industriel ou
non entreprise évidemment le tarif
réglementé de vente reste un élément de
stabilisation et Deon vous entend pas
très bien plus faceic je me rapproche du
micro
voilà je
non ça ça vous pouvez compter sur le
niveau d'énergie il y a pas de
problème je reviens à votre question sur
la programmation énergétique du futur
alors il il est clair que nous allons
vers davantage de besoins
électriques parce que les usages
électriques augmentent donc à commencer
par la mobilité la mobilité est en train
d'accélérer son transfert vers
l'électrification et donc nous aurons
besoin besoin de davantage
d'électricité nous avons également un
potentiel d'efficacité énergétique
inexploité et je tiens à le dire c'estd
que N nous nous arriverons à tenir nos
nos engagements si nous allons chercher
le potentiel d'efficacité énergétique
qui n'est pas totalement exploité
aujourd'hui j'ai consacré plus de 10 ans
d'une carrière industrielle sur ce
métierlà je sais que le potentiel est
encore extrêmement fort et même si le
métier de DF est de produire et de
vendre des mgaw je pense que dans
l'intérêt de la nation dans l'intérêt du
système il faut poursuivre nos efforts
d'efficacité énergétique
euh sur le mix électrique je crois qu'à
ce
stade il
est le mix électrique ne sera pas
Infiné défini
par par simplement une définition
exhanté de ce vers quoi nous devons nous
devons converger nous avons besoin d'un
système électrique qui fonctionne tout
le temps euh chacun des moyens de
production a ses propres
caractéristiques
elles ont et tous les moyens de
production décarbonés ont un intérêt ils
ont une un rôle à jouer dans ce système
électrique le système électrique doit
simplement être résilient en utilisant
la totalité de ces moyens de production
et donc nous devons être capable à
l'horizon 2035 2040 2050 d'avoir un
système électrique qui répond à la
demande de nos
concitoyens qui ne demandent pas
toujours la même puissance électrique
disponible mais qui demande que
lorsqu'ils ont besoin de la puissance
électrique elles soit au rendez-vous
face à ça nous avons des moyens de
production décarbonés intermittents qui
produisent quand les éléments le
décident c'est l'ensemble du
renouvelable nous avons des éléments
décarbonés commandables qui sont
l'électricité électronucléaire
électricité hydraulique nous avons même
dans l'hydraulique des capacités de
stockage que nous pouvons augmenter nous
aurons d'ici là une forme de
commandabilité associée à des formes de
stockage y compris probablement une
partie du véhicule électrique dont on
pourra déplacer la charge en fonction
des besoins mais nous avons nous avons
besoin de continuer de développer la
flexibilité de notre de notre dispositif
électrique pour qu'il soit résilient
face à de plus en plus d'instabilité
structurelle à la fois des consommations
et des productions et c'est ça Infiné
qui doit déterminer notre stratégie en
terme en terme de mix de production et
donc nous y travaillons bien sûr et
l'intérêt des travaux du RTE c'est qu'il
donne un éventail de possibilités fondé
sur une analyse économique très sérieuse
euh qui permet de positionner à la fois
les politiques publiques mais également
les travaux des opérateurs pour être
capable de répondre à ces enjeux euh sur
les recrutements sur lesquels vous
m'avez
interrogé nous sommes évidemment dans
une phase de d'accélération industrielle
de remonter en puissance industrielle je
dois dire que après un an dans
l'entreprise et après avoir rencontré
évidemment non seulement beaucoup de
clients mais également le plus de
collaborateurs poss possible à la fois
de DF et de nos partenaires industriels
je vois que la filière industrielle est
prête pour remonter en puissance les
compétences sont là elles ont été
mobilisées par exemple à très brève
échéance et à très grande échelle sur
l'énorme chantier de corrosion sous
contrainte donc démontrant que nous nous
savons mobiliser à très grande échelle
même si évidemment impact de de ce de ce
problème industriel a été
fort donc la capacité de réagir et de
structurer notre industrie et là
simplement il nous faut maintenant la
montée en puissance pour les années qui
viennent nous avons encore un peu de
temps avant que la construction
proprement dite des PR2 soit à son pic
je rappelle qu'un chantier de PR2 c'est
10 à 12000 personnes sur site pendant
les années de construction à la fois
génie civil puis intégration
électromécanique nous avons quelques
années avant cela mais il nous faut être
au rendez-vous de ce moment-là c'est un
travail territorial d'abord il nous faut
être capable de monter avec les élus des
territoires correspondants l'ensemble
des capacités humaines et des structures
d'accueil qui permettent d'aborder ces
chantiers qui deviennent assez vite le
plus grand chantier d'Europe pour être
au rendez-vous au moment où la
construction se fera et donc nous
abordons avec chacune des chacun des
territoires euh qui sont aujourd'hui
désignés cette cette préparation et nous
abordons évidemment de façon extrêmement
organisée l'ensemble des recrutement
nécessaire en commençant au collège et
en allant jusque l'ensemble de la
filière qui est suivie par l'Université
des métiers du nucléaire et qui nous
amènera je l'espère à voir beaucoup de
jeunes collaborateurs formés au moment
où nous aurons besoin de cette montée à
l'échelle
euh ça ne s'arrête pas là évidemment il
faut évidemment que nous continuions de
travailler sur notre propre organisation
et sur la façon dont nous travaillons
nous
EDF au sein du groupe EDF et vis-à-vis
de l'ensemble de nos partenaires
industriels euh c'est une filière que
j'ai vécu pour ma part en tant que
fournisseur donc je je je viens de la
filière d'une certaine manière et euh
nous avons engagé une transformation du
groupe qui est destiné à nous rendre
prêt pour cette phase industrielle euh
je vais pas être trop long sur les
détails parce que ça nous emmènerait
trop loin mais les les principes de
cette transformation du groupe sont de
renforcer les métiers qui concourent au
succès industriel de ce projet en
commençant par la maîtrise d'ouvrage
c'est la capacité de dire ce que le
client EDF en tant que producteur
d'électricité souhaite sur ces projets
ensuite en créant à nouveau au sein du
groupe EDF une grande direction de la
construction qui a existé dans les
années 80 90 au moment où ODF a raccordé
au réseau jusqu'à qu réacteurs par an
mais qui en l'absence de construction à
l'échelle c'était étiolé ou c'était
dispersé à à l'intérieur du groupe donc
il nous faut recréer cette capacité de
piloter la construction de piloter les
projets eux-mêmes de façon industrielle
et donc nous créons cette direction et
puis enfin il nous faut gérer les autres
métiers qui sont au sein du groupe
industriel euh au meilleur niveau
mondial toutes industries confondu pour
être capable d'être au rendez-vous et
donc ça ça concerne le pilotage de
l'ensemble de notre filière industrielle
ça concerne l'ingénierie
et ça concerne évidemment nos propres
activités industrielles qui aujourd'hui
sont essentiellement autour de Framatome
mais demain autour de Framatome et
d'Arabelle qui devrait nous rejoindre
bientôt enfin sur l'écosystème vous en
avez dit un mot madame la Présidente
mais écoutez c'est une vigilance de tous
les jours comme n'importe quel
industriel qui est tête de filière nous
devons avoir une vigilance de tous les
jours sur la totalité de notre
écosystème la totalité de nos
partenaires et donc nous travaillons
avec eux pour voir le maximum
d'anticipation possible sur leurs
besoins leurs stratégies leurs
évolutions potentielles et lorsque des
situations particulièr se produisent ben
nous suivons avec les pouvoirs publics
l'évolution de chacun de ces partenaires
aussi bien que nous pouvons le faire et
donc nous avons suivi évidemment toutes
les situations que vous avez cité voilà
ce que je voulais dire en propos
introductif pardon si j'étais un peu
long madame la Présidente merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président donc il y a vous
vous en doutez bien énormément de
questions donc si on veut arriver à
essayer de de toutes les passé je pense
qu'il faut vraiment vraiment vous
astreindre à être les plus synthétiques
poss possible donc on va prendre
l'ensemble des questions des rapporteur
soit donc Daniel grimier pierre cuipers
Jean-Jacques Michot et Fabien Guay qui
ont été soit rapporteur de projet de loi
soit de mission
d'information et Franck Ménonville qui
remplace Patrick Chauvet alors Daniel
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président chers collègues d'abord une
première question le Sénat était un
élément moteur sur la loi d'accélération
du nouveau nucléaire euh à l'époque
lorsque nous
avons voter ce texte vous étiez euh sur
euh avec la compilation des mesures qui
étaient à l'intérieur sur grosso modo 56
mois par considéré par EDF de gain de
temps est-ce qu'on est toujours
aujourd'hui dans cette perspective euh
de euh cette loi d'accélération de 56
mois
deuxème point qui est d'actualité qui a
failli être d'actualité sur ce texte
c'est
le la partie qui a été l'enjeu de la la
fusion entre l'ASN
l'IRSN et qui va bientôt réapparaître et
qui va nous être soumis quel est votre
point de vue sur cette fusion
rencontrez-vous aujourd'hui des
difficultés dans vos relations avec
l'autorité de contrôle ou l'expert en
sûreté et partage v les lignes rouges
fixées par le pex dans son étude sur le
sujet je pense ici à la séparation des
fonctions de contrôle et d'experts à la
publicité des décisions d'expertise au
maintien en bloc des activités de
recherche ou à la prise en compte
spécifique des activités commerciales et
de défense et enfin dernier point
monsieur le
Président on est à la croisée des
chemins l'énergie sera un élément
absolument stratégique sur la
décarbonation et sur la
réindustrialisation de la France et
l'électricité en fait partie aujourd'hui
des décisions ont été prises sur la
création de six nouveaux réacteur on
sait que c'est largement insuffisant le
Sénat avait d'ailleurs déjà dit pris
position dans ses travaux nous avons
besoin d'aller plus vite plus fort sur
le nucléaire plus vite plus fort sur
l'hydroélectricité plus vite plus fort
sur le
renouvelable il faut le financer vous
avez commencé à aborder à travers les
contrats à long terme on a besoin
d'avoir une comme vous l'avez dit une
visibilité une stabilité des prix sur
les électrrointensifs c'est à ce prix-là
que nous les garderons qu'il resteront
et qui se développeront en France mais
il y a pas que ces électrointensifs
l'ensemble de l'économie et des
particuliers des collectivités sont
concernés on est tout près de la fin de
l'arène on a besoin d'avoir la et je
pense que nous gagnerons la
réindustrialisation et elle
participera à une réponse car neutralité
carbone que si nous avons une
clairvooyance et une compétitivité sur
le prix de l'énergie et notamment
l'électricité on le voit à travers le
monde et j'aurais besoin d'y voir un peu
plus clair merci Daniel pierre
cuipers merci madame la présidente
monsieur le Président je souhaiterais
connaître votre point de vue sur les
futures lois de programmation
énergétique considérant que la ministre
chargée de la transition énergétique a
annoncé dans ce cadre une hausse de la
production d' cité nucléaire entre 360
et 400 TWh ainsi qu'une multiplication
totale voire par 2 voire par 3 du
solaire et une augmentation annuelle de
2 g GW sur l'éolien alors cela vous
paraît-il faisable sachant que la
production nucléaire n'a pas dépassé 279
TWh en 2022 que la multiplication prévue
pour le solaire est inférieure à celle
de 4 à 5 fois proposé par RTE et et que
l'augmentation prévue pour l'éolien est
supérieure à celle de 0,7 à 1,5 GWh
suggéré par RTE alors que pensez-vous
des énergies décarbonées au mises de ces
annonces gouvernementales je rappelle
que les filières nous avait présenté
pour 2030 des objectifs de 27,5 Gow et
de capacité pour
l'hydroélectricité de 680000 tonnes de
production pour l'hydrogène et de 80 TWh
de production pour le biogaz nous les
avons soutenus dans nos travaux
législatifs comme de contrôle les
hypothèses donc de RTE s'élève jusqu'à
28 GW pour l'hydroélectricité et 800000
tonnes pour l'hydrogène et 10 TWh pour
les bioénergies alors pouvez-vous nous
préciser votre vision sur ces énergies
ne doit-on pas faire davantage en
direction de
l'hydroélectricité et pour quelle
stratégie faut-il opter en matière
d'hydrogène faut-il le produire ou
faut-il l'importer merci Franck
mononville merci madame la présidente
monsieur le Président je voudrais donc
recueillir votre avis monsieur le
Président sur l'application de la loi
accélération de la production des
énergies
renouvelables ce texte en effet a
introduit de nombreuses dispositions en
faveur des énergies renouvelables et
vise à simplifier l'implantation le
raccordement des projets avec les
zones d'introduction donc de zones
d'accélération de comités de de projet
mais également la révision des schémas
régionaux de raccordement il a rénové
les appels d'offre en en les appliquant
donc en leur appliquant donc un bilan
carbone et une contribution territoriale
de nombreux outils de financement ont
été institués tels que les contrats de
long terme et les prises de
participation à l'initiative du Sénat
notamment un cadre législatif a été
conféré à l'agrivoltaïsme pandant queant
tandis que des souplesses
administratives ont été appliqué à
l'hydroélectricité et à l'hydrogène et
enfin la décarbonation des zones non non
interconnectés les ZNI ont été promu en
en substituant de la biomasse aux
énergies fossiles dans les centrale
thermique en outrem notamment quel est
votre avis l'avis de DF sur ces sur ces
novations et puis peut-être au-delà des
énergies renouvelables quel pourront
être le le rôle des SMR dans ce
dispositif euh si ce texte a rénové donc
le cadre législatif des concessions
hydroélectriqu s'agissant de
l'augmentation de de puissance et du
financement des investissements il n'a
néanmoins pas répondu au contentieux
européens qui oberse les perspectives du
secteur depuis plus de 20 ans le
regroupement donc des activités hydro
électrique de notre de votre groupe dans
une quasi régie et le basculement du
régime de concession vers celui des
autorisations en touretour était
envisagé donc dans la presse quelle est
la piste qui qui est la vôtre
aujourd'hui et quand sera-t-il mise en
œuvre ça sera--elle mise en œuvre il
nous reste Jean-Jacques Michot et
ensuite Fabien Guay oui madame madame la
Présidente Monsieur le monsieur le
Président Directeur Général je d'abord
en tant que sénateur de la rège
je vais rebondir ce qu'a dit mon mon
prédécesseur weton de l'hydroélectricité
des concessions mais ensuite en tant que
corapporteur de la mission
transpartisane sur nucléaire et
hydrogène parmi nos propositions nous
avions appelé à garantir l'énergie et et
l'hydrogène nucléaire et une à une
complète neutralité technologique dans
le cadre de Tex européen la tax conomie
européenne verte la directive sur les
énergies renouvelables ou le règlement
sur la réforme du marché de
l'électricité les compromis trouvés vous
en avez un petit peu parlé s'agissant de
l'inclusion de l'énergie nucléaire à la
taxonomie ou à l'hydrogène nucléaire à
la directive vous semble-t-il suffisant
pour garantir la compétitivité des
activités de votre groupe et les outils
de financement de long terme proposés
dans le cadre de la forme du marché de
l'électricité tel que les contrats pour
différence ou les accords d'achat
d'électricité vous paraissent-il adapté
pour le nucléaire pour le nouveau comme
pour l'existant pour notre part si nous
saluons les avancées réalisé il nous
semble que les les conditions fixées
sont encore au moins ambigues sinon
restrictive et après vous pourrez
répondre monsieur le Président merci
Madame la présidente monsieur le
Président permettez-moi aussi d'avoir un
mot pour cet agent
enedis qui est mort et penser à ses
camarades et sa famille on le dit pas
assez souvent mais les gazers
électriciens comme beaucoup de de
métiers qui agissent pour le service
public peuvent parfois malheureusement
payé le prix de leur vie et c'est les
mêmes d'ailleurs parfois que l'on
brocarde parce que il ils agissent dans
des manifestations pour défendre leurs
droits euh il ont aussi tout mon soutien
juste deux questions précises 60
milliards de dettte c'est c'est votre
principal problème il faut produire
investir et rendre service
euh comment faire avec
laaren c'est une question on a fait la
mission madame la Présidente vient le
redire où on préconisait ensemble
d'augmenter évidemment le prix tout en
restant sous le même Cotat moi
personnellement je je le dis comme ça je
pense quand même qu'il faut en finir
avec ce système qui a a sucé le sang de
de DF et qui et qui et qui aujourd'hui
depuis 15 ans ou sucit le sang oui bon
après on peut trouver à sper peu importe
en tout cas à dégradé EDF et n'a pas
permis la concurrence promise je me
rappelle de votre audition la première
fois vous avez dit j'arrive sur
l'arinene quelle est votre vision vous
pouvez y aller on est on est tout seul
personne nous regarde vous pouvez vous
pouvez vous lâcher sur cette question
non mais touteon 2025 c'est maintenant
donc l'année qui arrive pour EDF comme
pour les parlementaires pas que ça mais
la reen et sa réforme et qu'est-ce qui
va la remplacer va nous animer pendant
un an donc quelle est votre vision là il
faut faut faut faut y aller et la
deuxième chose c'est sur le marché vous
vous êtes maintenant un chef
d'entreprise unee entreprise nationale
réétatisée pas renationalisée réétatisée
avec un actionnaire unique l'État dont
on sait le débat que vous avez avec on
est de tout cœur avec vous euh sur le
marché moi je ne crois pas qu'on peut
avoir on peut avoir un marché ouvert au
cas V avec des entreprises privées et
puis EDF étatisé de toute façon
l'électricité ne peut pas être sur le
marché parce que c'est il y a pas de
marché sans stock voilà on produit on
consomme bon bref donc on a une question
moi je pense qu'il faut aller vers un
grand service public moi je le dis il
faut renationaliser ngj et total énergie
y aller donc c'est quoi c'est non mais
parce que
autrement la la la réforme du marché
européen tel qu'il est je finis par là
on a une question c'est que le prix ne
se rapproche plus du cout et les
contrats pour différen et les PPA en
réalité c'est fait pour sauver le marché
mais moi je pense qu'il faut sortir du
marché européen pas de l'interconnexion
ça c'est la fable qu'on n r compte parce
que de toute façon on est au centre des
interconnexions si on en sort il y a
plus de marché européen mais sortir du
système concurrentiel on ne s'en sortira
pas autrement et on a une vraie question
il y a 12 millions de précaires
énergétiqu et donc quelle est votre
vision aussi sur le retour des tarifs
réglementés pour les collectivités les
PM et
juste en 10 secondes est-ce que tout ça
c'est réalisable si EDF ne se concentre
pas sur le territoire national et
continue ces questions internationales
voilà pour répondre au 60 milliards de
dett voilà je merci Fabien monsieur le
PDG on attend vos
réponses merci madame la Présidente je
vais essayer de répondre
autant que je peux bien à tout le
monde monsieur le rapporteur
grémier la loi d'accélération du
nucléaire elle elle est elle est un vrai
plus notamment dans la capacité de gérer
en parallèle toute la phase de
préparation des projets dans lequel nous
avions jusqu'ici en fait des des
problématiques d'autorisation en série
donc en parallélisant les processus nous
avons effectivement gagné je ne sais pas
vous dire si c'est 56 mois mais nous
avons gagner beaucoup donc merci pour
cela c'est vraiment important sur ASN
RSN vous permettrez aux dirigeants de
l'entreprise qui est la contrôler
d'avoir une réserve de qui n'est pas de
forme sur la façon dont dont elle doit
être contrôlée sur un aspect aussi
essentiel que la Sûreté Nucléaire ce que
je peux dire simplement c'est que à
l'heure nous sommes et comp tenu des
enjeux que nous avons devant nous nous
devons marcher comme nous le faisons
aujourd'hui je dois dire avec un travail
très professionnel à la fois avec laasn
et avec l'IRSN mais avec une vision
d'organisation du travail de fluidité du
travail qui soit cohérente avec
l'ambition industrielle que nous avons
de construire beaucoup et d'opérer un
parc qui en même temps a besoin de de
continuer de se moderniser et donc la
façon dont ASN IRS
ensemble s'organiseront pour permettre
de poursuivre la relation de confiance
que nous avons avec l'un et avec l'autre
en ayant peut-être des outils qui
permettent de travailler plus facilement
plus rapidement ensemble nous permettra
je pense de relever ensemble l'un des
défis fondamentaux de l'industrie
nucléaire aujourd'hui qui est le temps
et la capacité de gérer en toute sûreté
mais dans un temps compatible avec nos
défis industriels l'ensemble des enjeux
qui sont devant nous
euh sur les besoins
d'énergie je crois qu'au total ce qu'il
faut que nous gardions tous en mémoire
c'est que même si nous avons une énergie
électrique en France qui est la plus
décarbonée au monde il nous reste 2
tiers de l'énergie consommée par notre
pays qui est carboné et donc notre notre
enjeu principal il est de faire le plus
vite possible de toutes les capacités
qui permettent de décarboner et ça
inclut évidemment plus de capacité
électrique au fond notre notre situation
est assez simple c'est si nous voulons
être sérieux je crois que nous voulons
tous être sérieux sur la décarbonation
de notre économie il faut aller chercher
les 2/ers de la consommation qui sont
aujourd'hui des consommations carbonées
et ça ça suppose de faire le maximum de
ce que l'on peut partout
euh monsieur cuipers
euh merci de de vos questions sur la loi
de programmation énergétique alors EDF
n'est que n'est que l'opérateur
industriel d'une partie
de de l'énergie française et n'a pas la
visibilité ni même d'ailleurs les
données hein que seul les pouvoirs
publics peuvent aggloméré en matière de
prévisibilité donc c'est bien au pouvoir
public de définir la trajectoire de nos
besoins énergétiques et les options que
nous devons aller chercher aux questions
que vous avez posé sur notre capacité à
produire nous étions effectivement à 279
TWh qui était la pire année vue de DF
depuis depuis la création du parc
nucléaire en raison du problème
industriel auquel nous av ont été
confrontés nous serons cette année dans
la fourchette annoncée de 300 à 330 TWh
nous continuerons d'augmenter l'année
prochaine et nous continuerons
d'augmenter l'année suivante donc oui à
l'horizon de temps concerné par la la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
nous nous voulons nous avons l'objectif
d'aller dans la gamme de 360 à 400 en
intégrant évidemment d'ici là le
raccordement de flamandville et en
continuant de travailler y compris sur
la puissance disponible
sur les réacteurs existants puisque nous
avons la capacité d'augmenter la
puissance marginalement mais
marginalement sur beaucoup de réacteurs
ça finit par faire une somme qui n'est
pas marginale sur sur la même période
donc cet objectif de 400 taw qui est un
chiffre qui peut paraître un peu
mythique qui n'a été atteint que
quelques années au au début quand le
parc était jeune je considère que c'est
notre objectif managérial que d'aller le
chercher sur les années qui
viennent euh sur les autres modes de
production que le
nucléaire il est difficile de faire des
projection sur la réalité de ce qui se
passera simplement on peut regarder ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que le solaire
notamment le solaire décentralisé a une
courbe d'accélération tout à fait réelle
qui permet à notre pays de rattraper euh
en tout cas de suivre la même courbe que
des pays qui n'ont pas la chance d'avoir
un parc nucléaire stable
depuis longtemps et qui on ou qui ont
des expositions solaires plus
importantes que le nôtre et donc pour
exemple le le l'autoconsommation
particulier sur l'année 2023 va doubler
par rapport à l'année
2022 donc on va passer à une centaine de
milliers de clients raccordés en
autoconsommation de plus que ce que nous
avions l'année dernière ce potentiel là
il permet d'abord à beaucoup de clients
de baisser leur fact électrique c'est
certes un investissement au moment où
vous faites l'investissement
d'autoconsommation mais ça baisse votre
facture électrique et derrière ça
contribue effectivement même si on les
voit pas forcément dans les chiffres de
production centralisé ça fait partie des
éléments de production disponibles à
l'échelle du pays donc cette cette
partie là du solaire elle a une
dynamique extrêmement forte aujourd'hui
dans notre pays et elle rejoint la
dynamique que j'ai pu observer dans mais
dans mon métier d'avant dans des pays
comme l'Australie ou d'autres qui sont
beaucoup beaucoup plus loin et beaucoup
plus avancés ce qui vient évidemment
avec des problématiques de stabilité et
de gestion de l'intermittence que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure auquel nous
devrons apprendre à faire face également
vous avez parlé de l'hydroélectricité
l'hydroélectricité fait partie des
potentiels qui ne sont pas complètement
exploités dans notre pays aujourd'hui
nous avons sur le seul périmètre de DF
probablement 3 GW de potentiel sans
création de nouveaux barrages en
amélioration de la la puissance
disponible ou en rehausse de
barrage ce qui permet évidemment ce qui
permettrait évidemment d'avoir davantage
de productible commandable des carbon
disponible et une faculté de retenue en
amont pour des usages autres que
l'hydroélectricité et pour permettre
d'adapter notamment nos régions du sud
au changement
climatique pour cela il nous faut un
certain nombre d'évolution du cadre
juridique dans lequel nous opérons pas
seulement EDF mais l'ensemble du secteur
puisque le constat que nous pouvons
faire à ce stade c'est que le régime des
concessions lui-même en réalité est
bloque
l'investissement donc ce n'est pas un
sujet de renouvellement de tel ou tel
concessionnaire mais bien d'être capable
d'imaginer un un nouveau régime qui soit
adapté au besoins de davantage
d'hydroélectricité et davantage de
retenus d'eau également dans notre pays
pour des besoins de soutien d'étiage ou
d'usage euh
différencier de l'eau donc pour cela
nous avons beaucoup travaillé avec
évidemment les administrations et avec
avec les pouvoirs
publics nous pensons à ce stade n nous
proposons en tout cas d'aller dans la
direction du régime d'autorisation qui
est le régime qui est à très très large
échelle le plus utilisé en Europe et qui
permet de dépasser cette problématique
ça n'est pas évidemment une évolution
simple donc il y a beaucoup de travail
en cours et il a apptiendra évidemment
au gouvernement de prendre la décision
du régime le plus adapté pour notre pays
euh monsieur j'espère que j'ai répondu à
vos questions
l'hydrogène l'hydrogène est à un stade
maturité industrielle qui n'est pas
comparable aux autres évidemment
l'hydrogène doit prendre une place dans
l'ensemble des dispositifs de d'énergie
décarboné l'hydrogène a besoin d'être
produit il a besoin d'être utilisé et à
ce stade donc nous participons nous au
travers de notre filiale notamment qui
s'appelle hamic à un certain nombre de
projets de production d'hydrogène et
d'utilisation
d'hydrogène et pour tout cela
l'hydrogène a besoin d'un modèle
économique comme tout le monde pour
l'instant pour des raisons de maturité
technologique ou de modèle économique et
souvent les deux les projets que nous
testons sont je pourrais les qualifier
de pré-industriel c'est-à-dire que nous
avons des démonstrateurs ou des projets
pré industriel qui vont chercher des
ordres de grandeur de puissance de
dizaines de
mégaw la plupart du temps couplé à un
usage industriel immédiat soit du
transport soit de l'usage d'hydrogène
décarboné sont des projets intéressants
je considère que nous apprenons beaucoup
sur ces projets et la principale
question que nous nous posons sur ces
projets c'est comment passer à l'échelle
et donc pour être capable d'aller
chercher des dizaines de terraw
évidemment il faut que nous arrivions à
franchir cette cette première étape mais
il y a pas de raison qu' n n arrivions
pas puisque il y a d'autres secteurs le
nucléaire il y a un peu plus longtemps
le renouvelable il y a une vingtaine
d'années qui ont commencé par des
projets de démonstrateur et qui ensuite
ont vécu leur montée en puissance
industrielle et donc nous souhaiterons
évidemment être au rendez-vous de ces
enjeux mais pour l'instant ce que je
peux dire c'est qu'il nous il me semble
que c'est une filière qui est au stade
pré-industriel euh monsieur Ménonville
euh sur
euh euh sur le le renouvelable euh bah
je je refais la même réponse qui qu'il
nous faut le plus de tout en réalité
mais tout ça dans dans un équilibre du
système électrique voilà c'est c'est
pour moi les deux messages simples c'est
il nous faut le plus de production
électrique possible de tous les modes de
production avec un œil euh vigilant sur
l'équilibre du système électrique parce
que si euh j'ai trop d'intermittent je
ne sais pas compenser pour assurer la
stabilité du réseau électrique en
permanence euh donc oui l'accélération
du renouvelable est parfaitement
souhaitable et la loi d'accélération sur
le renouvelable permet de le faire euh
donc on le voit dans les dans les
différents domaines euh il y a
évidemment quand on parle de
renouvelable au sol vous êtes tous des
élus donc vous le savez mieux que moi
une création de consensus qui est qui
doit être travaillé pour que la la
production de renouvelabl au sol qu'on
parle d'éolien ou de solaire soit admise
soit comprise et ce n'est pas toujours
facile celle qui comme je le disais tout
à l'heure a la plus grande progression
parce qu'elle est la plus consensuelle
aujourd'hui et celle qui est basée soit
sur des zones qui sont déjà artifici sur
des zones déjà artificialisées pour être
simple parce que elle est perçue à juste
titre comme ne sacrifiant pas autre
chose et donc là-dessus nous voyons une
accélération très forte et elle permet
évidemment d'avoir une puissance
disponible supplémentaire et également
parce que que je l'ai observé de
nombreuses fois de permettre lorsque
cette production est internalisée par un
client qu'il soit particulier ou
entreprise partir du moment vous devenez
vous-même producteur d'électricité vous
faites attention à votre
consommation et donc ça permet également
de faire des pas gigantesques dans le
sens de l'efficacité énergétique en
réalité sur
euh je crois que j'ai répondu à votre
question sur sur
l'hydroélectricité et sur la
décarbonation en ZNI merci d'avoir posé
la question c'est évidemment une
problématique fondamentale sur lequelle
nous avons nous regardons évidemment
chacun des territoires des adénis un par
un avec l'objectif d'être souvent
d'ailleurs en avance sur la métropole en
terme de de zéro carbone donc je suis
très heureux après un long
parcours de procédures diverses d'avoir
enfin lancé le chantier de la centrale
de larau en Guyane qui est absolument
essentiel pour l'équilibre du réseau
électrique guyanis qui est soumis à
beaucoup de beaucoup de difficultés mais
qui est également totalement décarboné
voilà un exemple mais notre objectif
c'est d'être vraiment sur chacun de ces
territoires parmi les premiers
territoires à être à zéro carbone sur la
production
électrique monsieur
Michot j'espère que j'ai répondu sur
l'hydroélectricité
sur votre question sur la neutralité
technologique euh écoutez je sais que
c'est un un combat de chaque instant
mené avec beaucoup d'opiniatreté
par par l'ensemble des pouvoirs publics
et en particulier par la ministre de
l'Énergie et qu'il faut en permanence
faire preuve de vigilance donc nous nous
sommes juste un opérateur industriel
mais on peut contribuer à la vigilance
donc vous pouvez compter sur notre
vigilance effectivement la neutralité
technologique dès lors qu'on est
d'accord sur l'objectif de
décarbonation tout ce qui concourt doit
être considéré de de façon homogène et
c'est évidemment une une vigilance qui
nécessite attention
euh sur les outils de financement je
pense qu'il faut considérer les outils
de financement comme une boîte à outils
euh c'est une boîte à outils assez large
elle est elle est elle est bien fournie
et tous les éléments de la boîte à
outils peuvent être utiles à un moment
et ensuite ce qui détermine l'intérêt
d'utiliser tel ou tel élément de la
boîte à outil est-ce qu'il faut un CFD
pour tel projet est-ce qu'il faut euh
tel type de garantie sur tel autre ell
sont les circonstances particulières à
chaque projet ou à chaque industriel ou
à chaque situation qui peuvent être
assez nombreuses en Europe et assez
diverses euh et donc je pense que cette
approche de boîte à outil est plutôt
plutôt positive euh et elle a contribué
aussi à dépassionner le débat européen
euh sur qui a de quoi parce que ça c'est
générateur de friction et donc de délais
et donc d'imperfection en terme de
développement d'infrastructure euh et
énergétique et notamment énergétique
décarboné
euh monsieur
gay m'invité à me lâcher je je je feris
je ferai preuve d'un contrôle
irréprochable malgré malgré malgré la
tentation à laquelle vous me soumettez
euh j'espère avoir répondu déjà sur la
façon dont nous pouvons aborder le futur
euh il est clair qu' système dans
lequel l'opérateur industriel EDF a
l'obligation de vendre et en réalité les
2/ers de sa production nucléaire en
dessous de ses coûts n'a pas d'avenir ça
c'est clair bon ce dispositif il prend
fin légalement fin 2025 et et tout le
travail en cours tout le travail en
cours que j'essayie d'écrire dans mon
propos introductif et destiné à à lui
trouver ouver un remplacement qui se
fasse à la
satisfaction des de l'ensemble des
parties prenantes c'est que si si on
allait vers des règles qui sont
peut-être perçu comme un irvana
potentiel pour EDF disantf est libre de
faire ce qu'il veut et que ça ne tienne
pas pour les clients bah ça tiendrait
pas longtemps c'est clair donc il nous
faut trouver quelque chose qui donne de
la pérenité de la stabilité de la
visibilité à tout le monde alors est-ce
que ça peut être dans une économie qui
est fixée par celle qu'on a fixé il y a
10 12 ans et qui n'a pas bougé de plus
depuis non ça peut pas être dans cette
économie là est-ce que ça doit être dans
une économie qui permet la vision de
long terme oui c'est d'abord notre
objectif et donc proposer cette vision
de long terme c'est bon pour les clients
et c'est bon pour EDF et donc c'est pour
ça que nous poussons d'abord dans cette
direction et ensuite naturellement ça
doit être complété par des garanties ou
des capacités de contrôle qui sont donné
au pouvoir public pour veiller à ce que
l'on reste dans des dans des domaines
qui sont cohérents avec notre économie
de l'électricité et donc l'économie
deedf aussi euh après bon vous vous
poussez le raisonnement jusqu'à imaginez
un un autre mode d'organisation moi ce
que je peux vous dire comme simplement
chef d'entreprise c'est
que je je crois que je saurais comment
on peut gérer EDF dans un
monopole régulé en ayant la to ité de la
capacité de production électrique du
pays et des clients ça a bien marché
pendant un certain nombre d'années donc
je saurais faire mais il se trouve que
c'est pas le monde dans lequel nous
sommes le monde dans lequel nous sommes
il a créé un marché européen dont aussi
nous avons bénéficié c'est que l'année
où on avait un problème industriel où il
a fallu être capable
d'importer beaucoup d'électricité on
était content de l'avoir et toutes les
autres années c'est les 20 autres années
plus cette année où on exporte entre 7
et 15 GW par jour ver vers nos vers nos
voisins on n'est pas mécontent de le
faire non
plus oui mais ça ça marchait moins bien
ça marchait moins bien et donc donc ce
qu'il nous faut c'est être capable de
d'inventer des règles qui qui
fonctionnent dans ce monde là et et je
pense que nous nen sommes pas loin donc
donc c'est làdessus que nous travaillons
voilà je crois que en tout cas j'ai
essayé de répondre à toutes vos
questions
merci beaucoup alors on va essayer de
prendre des questions peut-être deux par
deux et rapide s'il vous plaît sinon on
passera pas tout le monde pierre
meddevieille Serge
miloup monsieur le Président on peut
toujours sur le éviter les questions
redondantes les discussions sur la PR
arine sont au cœur de l'actualité le
nouveau mécanisme vers lequel on se
dirige celui des des contrats pour
différence donc le règlement européen en
cours de discussion on parle aussi de
plancher au cas la situation de marché
se renverserait qu'il fallit AER EDF si
les prix sont trop bas néanmoins la mise
en place d'un plancher ne semble pas
encore acté si nous av'avons pas de prix
plancher que se passera-t-il si les prix
baisse soudainement et trîn des pertes
pour EDF et donc une intervention
nécessaire de l'état des contribuables
français pouvez-vous nous conformer
confirmer pardon que vous vrez pour la
mise en place d'un plancher comme nous y
invite le règlement européen Serge
mergou oui monsieur le Président
Directeur Général madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues une question
d'actualité allez-vous avec RT
prendre un certain nombre d'initiatives
pour
accélérer la mise sous terre des des
lignes électriques qui qui qui pose
problème alors je sais que c'est d'abord
RTE mais c'est aussi le rôle des DF et
sur Laar le problème a déjà été
largement évoqué mais il y a des
questions précises sur lesquell vous
n'avez pas répondu ou sur lequel moi
j'attends un certain nombre de questions
d'abord si si je m'aintiens au rapport
de l'ancien président de la commission
des affaires européennes Sabine tilae
qui date de 2021 la reine entre
guillemets explique en grande partie la
situation déficitaire desedf ce
mécanisme affaiblit l'entreprise
publique et limite ses revenus donc vous
Président Directeur Général desdf
qu'attendez-vous de la fin de l'arè
concrètement quelle option
privilégiez-vous dans le mécanisme
fixation des prix et comment selon vous
la fin de ce dispositif peut-il être une
opportunité pour renforcer notre
souveraineté énergétique et enfin
pourquoi ne pas utiliser ce moment qui
est un moment important fin 2025 pour
freiner ou revenir sur la libéralisation
du marché de l'énergie et enfin quelle
place doit jouer selon vous l'État dans
le processus de régulation des prix
merci sergesieur
président merci beaucoup
[Musique]
euh
donc vous vous m'avez
demandé si
euh
pardon
euh vous
m'avez vous m' demandé sur le
plancher monsieur
mdeviel encore une fois nous avons une
boîte à outils qui est permise par le
règlement européen il y a aucune
obligation d'utiliser telle ou telle
partie de la boîte à outils nous nous
arrivons devant nous avec un certain
nombre de de sujets qui nous faut
traiter le premier c'est la fin de
l'arène qu'est-ce que nous faisons
postarène le deuxième c'est comment nous
finançons nos futurs réacteurs voilà et
donc la boîte à outil doit être utilisée
pour ce qu'elle apporte sur l'ensemble
de ces
questionsl
le la discussion que nous avons
aujourd'hui sur le postaren elle nous
conduit à regarder dans la boîte à
outils ce qui permet de tirer nos
relations commerciales le plus possible
vers le long terme parce qu'au fond
c'est l'instrument commercial sans aide
d'État qui apporte la meilleure garantie
à la fois au clients et à EDF et donc il
ne suppose pas que nous ayons une
discussion d'aide
d'État là où un CFD quelle qu'en soit la
nature à partir du moment où il y a un
plancher puisque c'est une garantie
donnée à l'opérateur que ce soit sur un
futur projet ou sur un actif existant le
plancher doit être négocié comme une
aide d'État et quand vous négociez une
aide d'État par définition il peut y
avoir des contreparties euh les
contreparties étant sur
l'entreprise ou sur sur plein de
paramètres qui peuvent être mis dans la
discussion de contrepartie donc la
discussion que nous avons aujourd'hui
elle est destinée à trouver le meilleur
chemin possible à la fois sur le futur
postarè sur nos actifs existants et sur
le financement du futur en ayant un
chemin soutenable pour ODF mais qui doit
être un chemin soutenable à la fois
économiquement et
industriellement et ce que nous pensons
aujourd'hui c'est que un chemin qui est
fait d'un accord commerci industriel
avec nos clients à à la plus large
échelle possible tirant nos relations
vers le long terme et ce qui donne le
meilleur effet pour les clients et pour
nous que ça doit être complété par un
pouvoir de contrôle qui reste dans la
main des pouvoirs publics qui fait en
sorte d'abord de surveiller le marché y
compris EDF dans le marché et qui en
plus donne au pouvoir public la capacité
d'intervenir pour compléter ce que le
marché ne ferait pas bien voilà le
dispositif sur lequel
nous sommes
aujourd'hui ensuite je crois que je
réponds en même temps à la question sur
laarine en ayant dit ça j'espère en tout
cas alors on passe à pardon j'ai pas
répondu à la question sur j'ai pas
répondu la question sur RTE j'ai pas
répondu à la question sur sur RTE et sur
l'enfouissement
alors pardon je reviens donc juste sur
la question de l'enfouissement
donc alors je je me sens pas compétent
pour vous répondre sur l'enfouissement
des lignes à très haute tension de RTE
qui sont qui sont vraiment une
problématique particulière en revanche
pour ce qui est de l'enfouissement des
lignes d'énedis hein puisque là
l'essentiel de l'Impact a quand même été
les arbres tombent difficilement sur sur
les lignes à très haute tension parce
qu'elles sont très hautes elles tombent
plus facilement malheureusement sur les
lignes à basse tension ou ou sur les
lignes moyenne tension HTA comme on dit
euh puisqu'elles sont elles sont à
moindre hauteur donc l'enfouissement
évidemment quelque chose qui est déjà
fait à l'échelle industrielle puisque 98
% des chantiers que nous faisons depuis
99 sont enfouis euh donc on enfouit tout
ce qu'on peut d'une certaine manière euh
simplement on a des dizaines de milliers
de kilomètres de ligne existant euh qui
euh pour une partie ne sont pas
enfouissables he quand vous êtes dans le
rocher c'est pas
enfuissable et qui évidemment
nécessiterait un temps extrêmement long
pour enfouir la totalité pour autant on
a augmenté la côte part du réseau de
distribution en fou de un peu plus de 30
% en 99 à 50 % aujourd'hui et avec ça on
est dans la moyenne européenne
aujourd'hui évidemment il y a des pays
plus denses que la France qui ont des
taux plus élevés d'enfouissement parce
que ils sont urbains au péri urbain dans
dans dans leur quasi totalité euh et
avec le taux que nous avons nous
ressemblons à peu près au pays qui ont
la même densité que nous euh donc pour
compléter ça évidemment nous avons
beaucoup progressé je pense depuis 30
ans euh enfin depuis 24 ans sur la
capacité d'intervention sur la
planification sur l'identification euh
des problématiques de coupure enedis est
est reconnu hein année après année comme
le meilleur réseau du monde
régulièrement notamment sur sa capacité
de de pilotage c'est considéré par un
organisme indépendant comme le réseau le
le plus intelligent au monde mais
également ce qui a permis sur la tempête
là de alors que l'impact sur la la
région Bretagne et sur la région
Normandie est trois fois celui de la
tempête de 99 il y a des endroits du
réseau Marianne Legot la patronne d'edis
a utilisé le terme Hach menu c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé
c'est-à-dire que tout est détruit en
réalité dans certains endroits et en
l'occurrence l'enfouissement n'aurait
pas changé grand-chose puisque ce sont
les postes mêmes qui ont qui sont qui
sont directement détruit dans ce cas-là
avec l'effet d'un cyclone en réalité
donc dans ce cas-là il nous faut être
capable de
reconstruire très rapidement et ce qui
fait la différence aujourd'hui par
rapport à 99 la raison pour laquelle une
semaine plus tard et j'espère que d'ici
la fin de la semaine on aura encore
beaucoup progresser malgré le fait qu'on
va chercher maintenant des situations
individuelles très très compliquées
parce que qu'elles sont
loin c'est la planification et la
qualité de l'information c'estàd que
nous avons des systèmes d'information
qui permettent de savoir exactement où
le problème se
passe pas besoin de le chercher très
très longtemps on est capable d'aller
très très vite à l'endroit où la coupure
a eu lieu et le deuxième élément c'est
l'anticipation grâce à l'initiative de
de mon prédécesseur François roussli qui
a créé les forces d'interaction
d'intervention rapide de l'électricité
après la tempête de 99 c'est comme ça
qu'on a pu mobiliser 3 100 personnes
avant même que la tempête ne tape et
donc les gens étaient sur place avec des
hélicoptères au moment où les dégâts
avaient lieu et étaient capable
d'intervenir dès que le vent avait
baissé voilà voilà les éléments sur
lesquels nous agissons en priorité pour
compléter ce que nous faisons aussi vite
que possible sur l'enfouissement merci
Sébastien plat Yannick
Jadeau madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues monsieur le Président
Directeur Général les échanges que vous
avez avec le gouvernement où il est
évoqué la possibilité de barê pour
récupérer une partie des bénéfices des
volumes d'électricité que DF vendrait
sur le marché de gros le le contract for
difference en se basant sur un prix de
140 € le le mgaw certaines estimations
font état d'un bénéfice pour F pouvant
aller jusqu'à 7 milliards d'euros sur
une année compte tenu des prix élevés de
de l'électricité de la nécessité de
soutenir les entreprises et le tissu
économique français et les ménages ne
faudrait-il pas mieux agir sur le prix
plutôt que de générer autant de
bénéfices par ailleurs dans son bilan
prévisionnel 2023 RTE considère que la
France a les moyens de nourrir la double
ambition à la fois de
réindustrialisation et de décarbonation
de l'industrie grâce à une électricité
décarbonée et compétitive pour se faire
quel niveau de prix visez-vous pour
réussir cette réindustrialisation
sachant que le gouvernement allemand
appelle un prix cible de 60 € le mgaw
pour ces industries à ce prix-là et
malgré notre parc nucléaire pourra-t-on
conserver pour notre industrie un
avantage compétitif sur nos voisins
allemands merci Yannick jade merci
madame la Présidente merci monsieur
monsieur le le président heureux pour
cette audition vous n'ayez pas encore
démissionné
mais il paraît que les négociations vont
bien donc tant mieux trois questions
très courtes vous avez évoqué pour vous
citer nous devons définir parlant de le
PR2 nous devons définir l'objet que nous
voulons construire à quel pourcentage
d'état d'avancement de conception vous
évaluez le PR2 30 40 60 % de conception
deuxième question rattachée à
ça comment arrivez-vous finalement à
donner ce que pourrait être le prix au
mgaw d'un PR2 avec une telle incertitude
sur l'objet que vous voulez construire y
compris on entend des chiffres qui sont
inférieurs à celui que vous réclamez
pour le nucléaire amorti ce qui est
toujours un peu
surprenant deuxième question très courte
quel pourcentage vous donnez de votre
investissement entre le nucléaire et les
énergies renouvelables pour les an 10
ans à venir 3è question nous sommes dans
un monde très instable quel est le plan
on parle beaucoup vis-à-vis de la Russie
de dérisquer nos investissements comment
vous évaluez votre stratégie de
réduction du risque vis-à-vis de la
Russie ou des pays sous emprise de la
Russie que ça concerne le nucléaire ou
notre technologie
merci
à vous monsieur le Président merci
madame la
Présidente je réponds à Monsieur plat
d'abord pour
commencer alors l'ORD de grandeur de 140
€ du mgawh n'est pas n'est pas dans lesp
de ce que de ce que nous imaginons he je
tiens à vous rassurer
là-dessus tout le monde je pense ça en
tête les travaux de la creux sur
l'estimation des coûts de DF y compris
d'ailleurs la façon dont il faut les
interpréter je cite la présidente de la
creue elle-même en disant que euh ces
travaux sont faits dans l'hypothèse où
EDF aurait un prix fixe ce qui n'est pas
le cas nous sommes évidemment dans un
prix qui est mobile euh donc voilà les
coûts de DF sont sur la partie de
nucléaire historique sont au-dessus de
60 60 c'est le chiffre de la creux ils
sont au-dessus ils sont pas très loin
au-dessus mais donc qu's soit entre plus
proche de 70 voilà un ordre de grandeur
qui définit notre économie sur le parc
existant sur le parc existant euh donc
naturellement il nous faut être capable
de vendre en moyenne notre électricité
un peu au-dessus de ça pour être capable
de contribuer au financement des des de
notre continuité d'exploitation
c'est-à-dire du renouvellement du parc
sur des actifs nouveaux euh et donc nous
avons des discussions qui sont voilà
dans ces zonesl qui permettent d'avoir
je l'espère un un cadre qui soit
soutenable pour tout le monde qui soit
soutenable pour le pays et qui soit
soutenable pour EDF soutenable pour au
pays pour le pays qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire il y a un point important qui est
que tout le monde n'a pas besoin de la
même
électricité et il est clair que entre un
industriel qui a besoin d'une grande
quantité d'électricité mais qui est
capable d'avoir un accord avec EDF dans
lequel il prend des risques de
production il est capable d'effacer sa
propre consommation de
façon immédiate ou de façon prédictive
il est capable de s'engager à 15 ans il
est capable de faire tout un tas de
choses qui nous permettent d'avoir une
discussion d'industrielle à Industri
et puis en particulier il y a pas du
tout le même type de besoin ni donc les
mêmes capacités vu de DF à former un
prix aux mêmes endroits donc il nous
faut évidemment être capable d'établir
une distribution de prix qui reflète la
nature différente de ces relations que
nous avons avec différentes clientèles
et dans ce cadre là oui nous souhaitons
évidemment avoir l'électricité la plus
compétitive possible pour les
industriels pas seulement
électrointensifs ça fait partie des
objectifs stratégiques du pays et euh
largement euh annoncé par le président
de la République dès son discours de
Belfort dans lequel évidemment s'inscrit
le groupe
euh monsieur jado
euh euh notre PR2 est un stade de
conception détaillé à ce stade donc
voilà dans un je ne sais pas quel
parallèle je peux prendre pour pour pour
pour représenter ce qu'est la conception
détaillée j'ai tendance à prendre la
cuisine comme comme comme
comparable je pense dans tout ce qui est
les dans ce qui tout ce qui définit les
objets essentiel de du réacteur on est à
80 90 % à ce
stade simplement voilà dans la cuisine
IKEA vous n'avez fini de monter la
cuisine que quand vous avez tout y
compris les petites vis et voilà voilà
et donc c'est voilà donc nous entrons
dans la
phase de conception y compris de de de
du détail du schéma d'exécution voilà
c'est que même voilà dans un schéma
électrique on dit voilà vous avez le
schéma de conception si vous avez le
schéma d'exécution on est dans la phase
dans laquelle on commence à définir les
schémas d'exécution et ça va répondre en
partie à votre question sur le prix
parce que le prix d'un d'un objet
industriel comme celui-ci c'est quoi
c'est l'objet qu'on construit le temps
qu'on y met et sa structure de
financement et donc il nous faut encore
beaucoup travailler un peu travailler
sur l'objet et c'est pour ça qu'on y
travaille avec l'ensemble de fili
industriel beaucoup travailler sur le
temps et travailler sur la structure de
financement et c'est l'ensemble des
trois qui nous déterminera Infiné à
forceor sur les objets récurrents c'est
pour ça nous devons nous focaliser
stratégiquement sur la performance que
nous atteignons en objet récurrent pour
faire en sorte que cet objet récurrent
il soit dans la zone de
performance qui est qui est souhaité à
cet horizon de temps est-ce que je suis
capable de vous dire quelle sera la zone
de performance de l'électricité en 2040
ou 2050 si je l'étais peut-être que je
ferai pas ce métier c'est possible mais
je pense que nous devons tout faire pour
être capable d'être euh au rendez-vous
et pour y être il nous faut travailler
sur ces trois paramètres et c'est
l'objet de la phase d'optimisation dans
laquelle nous entrons
euh le pourcentage du nucléaire et des
énergies renouvelables sur notre
investissement euh dans notre plan à
moyen terme je commencerai par dire
qu'est-ce qui est France et qu'est-ce
qui est pas France puisque j'ai eu cette
question tout à l'heure et je n'y ai pas
répondu je m' je m'en aperçois euh
aujourd'hui euh notamment parce que nous
sommes dans une phase de intense sur le
projet inclle point au Royaume-Uni qui
nous permet d'être au rendez-vous sur la
filière parce que s'il y avait pas eu ce
projet on ne serait pas au rendez-vous
aujourd'hui notre équilibre
d'investissement et 65 % France 35 %
hors France euh l'ensemble des enjeux de
la transition énergétique française vont
nous amener à 00 % en France euh et le
reste ne veut pas dire que nous ferons
moins à l'international nous ferons
différemment c'estàd que nous sommes
dans un métier construction de
production électrique qui attire
beaucoup d'investisseurs mais qui a peu
de savoir-faire il se trouve que nous
nous avons le savoir-faire et donc nous
sommes capables de travailler comme nous
le faisons depuis longtemps mais on va
le faire à plus grande échelle avec des
co-investisseurs dans lequels la côte
part de DF est beaucoup plus faible donc
c'est comme ça que nous allons nous
allons travailler sur nucléaire versus
ENR euh je pense qu'on peut parler d'à
peu
près 70 30 difficile de vous dire ça
très précisément sur toutes les années
mais 70 300 à peu près je pense c'est le
bon ratio au sein des investissements de
production de
[Musique]
DF et enfin réduction du risque
vis-à-vis de la
Russie je commencerai par dire
tranquillement que nous ne sommes pas
dépendants nous sommes pas dépendants
donc nous nous nous avons euh euh voilà
nous avons une une capacité euh
que peu de pays ont je pense y compris
les grandes puissances euh de traiter
l'ensemble de la filière euh à mon aval
y compris construction euh sur sur
l'ensemble de nos métiers ça suppose de
la vigilance comme je répondais tout à
l'heure à madame la Présidente euh mais
nous ne sommes pas dépendants euh de de
d'industriel li à la Russie en quoi que
ce soit ça ne veut pas dire que nous
n'avons pas un une
utilité dès lors que nous sommes
évidemment 100 % compatibles avec les
régimes de sanction à à travailler avec
tel ou tel mais nous ne nous mettons pas
nous ne sommes pas et ne nous mettrons
pas en situation de dépendance sur
aucune de nos technologies merci Sylvia
de Noël Martine Berté merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président une
très courte question concernant les
concessions hydroélectriques vous
militez pour le passage du régime
concessif au régime d'autorisation je
souhaitais savoir si vous pensez que
cette solution permettrait de sold
définitivement le contentieux entre la
France et la Commission européenne sur
ce sujet merci Marti merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président
Directeur Général j'aimerais revenir sur
les enjeux des discussions actuelles
avec les industriels et particulièrement
avec les électros et hyper électro
intensif donc il faut bien sûr des prix
qui soient fixés ex et pas expost pour
assurer une meilleure visibilité mais
pour l'instant enfin au niveau des
discussions les prix sont encore enfin
le plafond est encore trop haut pour que
les industriels puissent être
compétitifs à l'international et aussi
pouvoir répondre aux enjeux de
décarbonation de leur production donc je
voulais savoir quelle était votre vision
et est-ce qu'il est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas que ce serait le moment donc
à côté des contrats long terme de type
contrat d'allocation de production
nucléaire qui concernerait un tout petit
nombre d'industriels mais qui en ont
vraiment besoin est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas que le temps est venu de
lancer la deuxè phase
d'excelcium qui est une solution déjà
disponible déjà négociée déjà validé par
la commission européenne je vous
remercie pardon merci mesdames madame
Noël la réponse sur le contentieux c'est
que selon nos analyses ou et
naturellement il faudra que nous
partagions C ces analyses le moment venu
avec les autorités communautaires mais
ça c'est au gouvernement de de décider
d'abord d'un schéma et ensuite de
définir les modalités et des calendriers
euh madame Bert sur d'abord je voudrais
dire que la discussion avec les
industrielles est
intense elle est elle est intense à
juste titre donc quand je dis qu'elle
est intense c'est que c'est tous les
jours euh
et tous les jours plusieurs fois avec
les industriels un par un et avec leurs
représentants avec les fédérations
d'industrie voilà notre mission c'est de
faire réussir l'industrie française
c'est c'est pas juste de faire réussir F
mais on pense qu'il faut quand même
faire réussir EDF pour que l'industrie
française réussisse donc c'est le chemin
que nous essayons de trouver avec
l'industrie
le le point fondamental de réussite tous
ensemble à ce
stade c'est d'être capable de
trouver un équilibre contractuel qui
marche la plupart du
temps avec différentes catégories
d'industriel et encore une fois les
besoins ne sont pas les mêmes en
fonction des différentes
catégories vous avez parlé des CAPN donc
sont des partenariats industriels dans
lequel nous nous sommes capables de
partager une forme de production
ensemble avec avec des risques partagés
c'est un des outils possibles euh il y a
euh au-delà de ces outils-là évidemment
euh le potentiel qui est énorme euh
d'utiliser également pour les
industriels euh les les les fameux
contrats à 5 ans qui peuvent compléter
des partenariats industriels et donc euh
comme dans n'importe quelle industrie
quand vous achetez euh que ce soit votre
votre cuivre ce qui était mon cas il y a
quelques années ou bien euh ou bien
votre électricité en général vous vous
regardez quand vous êtes l'industriel
qui achète vous regardez qu'est-ce qui
est à ma disposition et comment est-ce
que je vais pouvoir couvrir mes besoins
à long terme à moyen terme à court terme
en optimisant sur la durée l'ensemble de
mes conditions d'achat et donc ce que
nous voulons proposer aux industriels
d'abord ce sont les outils qui couvrent
ce long moyen et court terme en
permettant de répondre à l'objectif de
compétitivité pour un grand nombre
d'entre eux ce sont des discussions qui
euh relève simplement de la discussion
commerciale et au passage nous nous
avons évidemment une approche qui permet
euh sur les rubans à moyen terme donc
sur les horizons de 5 ans à nos à nos
concurrents d'offrir la même chose
puisque nous offrons euh notre
électricité sur un marché qui permet à
nos concurrents de se sourcer aux mêmes
conditions euh est-ce que une approche
de type consortium comme excelsum est
possible bah elle est possible quand
elle a de la valeur ajoutée euh et la
valeur ajoutée c'est par exemple de
permettre à des clients qui n'auraient
pas la taille critique individuellement
de se grouper parce qu'ils ont un
intérêt euh identique ou similaire o ils
ont les même forme de production la même
forme d'effacement le même type de de de
consommation euh de se grouper pour être
capable de de former un partenariat
industriel avec nous et là-dessus nous y
sommes ouverts bien sûr euh est-ce que
excelsum strict au sensu doit être
répliqué il y a plus de discussions
technique à avoir je vais pas me lancer
dans le débat technique parce que il y a
des éléments d'excelcium euh qui euh euh
qui voilà de notre point de vue ne sont
pas optimaux et et n'ont pas forcément
conduit à atteindre les objectifs que
excelcium recherchait à l'origine mais
en tout cas sur le principe d'être
capable de travailler avec plusieurs
types de clientèle pour notamment pour
les plus petits et les moyens être
capable d'accéder à des conditions
équivalentes oui nous y
travaillons avec la même fréquence
c'est-à-dire tous les jours merci alors
on a reméy Cardon et Philippe grovallet
merci madame la Présidente moi je
voulais poser une question alors on a
parlé effectivement des des
investissements massif et et du coup du
choix politique qu'il y a derrière
monsieur le PDG de DF qui est en réalité
simple mais plutôt coûteux je vous
l'accorde selon RTE effectivement on est
autour de 25 à 35 milliards d'euros par
an bref si on passe sur la planification
écologique puisque vous en avez
parlé de manière assez conséquente sur
la planification écologique on va devoir
toutes et tous accélérer la sobriété
collective par les moyens de transport
en commun que ça soit en zone rurale ou
en en zone P urbaine les bornes de
recharge également on va devoir aussi
accélérer le fait de euh relocaliser de
manière sectorielle les emplois on va
devoir aussi par par la suite accélérer
les investissement individuel vers un
usage d'électrification des des usages
bref étant donné que vous êtes vous avez
une certaine proximité avec le le bras
droit du du président de la République
je suppose que vous aurez l'occasion de
faire des des dîners en la matière et je
voulais vous proposer du coup une
citation à
méditer donc de Harry Bernard la manière
d'utiliser l'énergie dépend de la
structure économique et sociale du pays
structure qui devra évoluer radicalement
dans la décennies à venir face à
l'urgence climatique ma question est
simple cette électrification est t donc
compatible compatible avec l'adaptation
de la société dans le court délai imposé
par le changement planétaire merci
Philippe
crovalet merci je voudrais revenir sur
la tempête même si vous avez répondu
partiellement d'abord moi aussi pour
saluer le le travail et l'engagement
surtout de l'ensemble des salariés de DF
et des entreprise mais aussi l'ensemble
des agents du service public on ne salue
jamais assez le travail des agents du
service public surtout quand qu' le
rendent au péril de leur vie ma question
porte j'ai bien noté que vous évoquiez
la capacité que vous avez à repérer en
amont les points de vulnérabilité mais
êtes-vous en capacité de le faire à plus
long terme en en considérant que à la
fois les phénomènes climatiques que nous
connaissons dans l'Ouest je suis
sénateur de Loire Atlantique seront bien
plus fréquents et surtout bien plus
violents et les vents des vents à à 70
nœuds ou des vents à plus de 120 nœuds
ce n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
donc êtes-vous en capacité dans le temps
long de mesurer justement non plus
simplement une capacité à réparer mais
une capacité à investir pour que
l'ensemble des éléments de production de
transport et de distribution puisse
résister à des phénomènes climatiques
plus violents et et connaissant les
capacité d'investissement dont nous
avons parlé pour la production
aurez-vous encore quelques capacité avec
RTE bien sûr à faire face à ces
phénomènes parce que produire c'est bien
mais les Français seront attentifs aussi
à ce que l'électricité parviennent
jusqu'à leur domicile merci non
excusez-moi le le sénateur de Loire
Atlantique que je suis ne peux pas vous
interroger sur le projet d'éc combust
parce que si dans l'Ouest nous n'avons
pas de nucléaire nous avons quelques
idées merci deci Philip monsieur le
Président merci euh
euh monsieur Cardon écoutez là aussi si
j'avais une réponse certaine à cette
question la vi serait plus facile je
pense que c'est le défi de notre
génération
et et je crois que quand on veut on peut
voilà la seule réponse que je peux faire
à ce
stade et et je pense que c'est
absolument compatible avec avec la vie
de nos concitoyens c'est c'est c'est
tout à fait c'est pour ça que j'insiste
en permanence aussi sur l'efficacité
énergétique parce que quand on prend la
transition énergétique avec les
bénéfices de l'efficacité énergétique
c'est-à-dire qu'on fait attention à
notre énergie
consommée l'ensemble de l'exercice peut
être fait dans des conditions qui sont
économiques tout à fait soutenables
économiquement soutenable donc je pense
que c'est possible mais il faut d'abord
le vouloir et c'est vraiment je pense le
défi de notre génération euh monsieur
Gralet merci pour nos équipes vraiment
euh
oui les phénomènes climatiques sont
appelés à être plus fréquents et plus
violents euh et c'est pour ça que nous
continuons à à travailler sur le réseau
encore une fois je parle plus d'enedis
que de RTE avec une
anticipation des risques supplémentaires
ça veut pas dire qu'on arrivera à 100 %
de d'enfouissement et il y a des cas
dans lesquel l'enfouissement n'est pas
une bonne idée même du point de vue de
la résilience donc voilà donc quand on
est dans zones qui bougent quand on est
zones inondables et cetera et CEA donc
tout ça n'est pas forcément il y a pas
forcément une seule réponse mais il y a
une approche pragmatique à l'approche du
risque climatique que ce soit sur le
réseau ou sur les moyens de production
bien sûr nous avons un travail très
approfondi sur l'ensemble de nos moyens
de production sur leur adaptation et
leur préparation au changement
climatique dans tous les domaines
évidemment sur ecocombus c'est un sujet
qui
évidemment est donc concerne le futur
de la centrale de cordemet donc
écocombust et la partie de production de
Pelet qui est porté donc par un
industriel pas par ODF et donc nous
travaillons avec cet industriel pour
voir dans toute la mesure du possible
comment son projet peut-être porter et
peut être réaliste sur le plan
économique pour ce qui nous concerne
évidemment nous avons le souhait de
continuer de faire en sorte que le site
de production de CORDEM puisse continuer
bénéficier à l'ensemble de du de la
production nationale et en adaptant son
moyen de production pour le décarboner
le plus vite possible voilà voilà
comment
nous nous travaillons aujourd'hui sur ce
projet merci Bernard buit et Daniel
Laurent merci présidente monsieur le
Président une question rapide dans un
récent rapport la Cour des comptes a
pointé des dérives financières
importantes de la part du comité
d'entreprise EDF qui gère 386 millions
d'euros sans contat sans contrôle inter
dééficient quelle est votre analyse de
la
situation Daniel
oui monsieur le le président
euh sortir du marché européen semble
être une affaire compliqué avec les
divergences de fond entre la France et
l'Allemagne monsieur le Président
plusieurs questions comment l'accord
européen sur l'électricité affecte-t-il
la stratégie globale de DF en matière de
production d'électricité de distribution
l'accord européen prévoit une plus
grande intégration des marchés de
l'électricité comment cela
impactera-t-il les activités
commerciales deedf et sa position sur
ces marchés quelle répercussion l'accord
pourrait-il avoir sur les prix
deélectricité pour les consommateurs en
Europe et en France des mesures pour
atténuer ses impacts potentiels sur les
clients sont-elles
prévu a plusieurs questions mais
synthétiqu donc monsieur le Président
des réponses synthétiques pouron puisse
finir avec l'ensemble de nos collègues
euh je vais essayer d'être synthétique
alors la réponse à Monsieur Bui c'est
que j'ai bien noté le rapport de la Cour
des comptes il se trouve que le
dirigeant de DF a a beaucoup de choses à
gérer mais pas le comité central
d'entreprise donc donc voilà nous serons
un
partenaire en soutien et vigilant de
ceux qui ont dans la charge pour faire
en sorte que les remarques de la Cour
des comptes puissent conduire à un
progrès voilà euh
ensuite Monsieur
Laurent la la plus grande intégration du
marché de l'électricité
[Musique]
elle encore une fois je disais tout à
l'heure que l'accord est historique dans
le sens où pour la première fois il y a
un vrai consensus européen sur la façon
dont ce marché est structuré et ce qui
manquait à ce marché c'était la vision
de long terme donc en cela j'y vois une
bonne nouvelle parce que à partir du
moment où l'ensemble de nos voisins et
nous-mêmes avons la capacité de nous
projeter en tant qu'industriel vers le
long terme en ayant cette vision de long
terme du marché d'électricité les les
défauts du marchéé
d'aujourd'hui qui a plein de qualités
mais qui avait quelques défauts et qui
sont notamment son instabilité dû au
fait qu'il est trop court terme sont
appelés à s'atténuer en tout cas c'est
notre objectif commun et c'est bien ça
qui est appelé par l'accord sur le sur
les règles de
marché donc moi j'en attends un impact
positif pour nos
concitoyens évidemment
ensuite notre notre avenir
énergétique à ce stade je pense qu'il
est difficile de l'envisager à l'échelle
hexagonale seulement puisque nous avons
des tonnes d'interdépendances et donc il
nous faut être capable de bâtir avec nos
voisins européens en dépassant de temps
en temps nos barrières et dans certains
cas c'est difficile on a pu le voir pour
arriver à bâtir un projet commun qui
soit autour de la décarbonation et qui
permettent le succès de la décarbonation
je crois qu'on peut y arriver ça
nécessitera encore certainement beaucoup
de
travail et en tout cas l'élément pardon
pour terminer làdessus pardon madame la
Présidente l'élément sur lequel en tant
qu'opérateur moi je souhaite être
vigilant c'est la stabilité du système
électrique dans son ensemble hein si
nous nous avons un système électrique
qui est par construction équilibré entre
des moyens de production décarbonés
commandables et des moyens intermittents
et que tous nos voisins fa des choix de
production intermittente évidemment ça
aurait des conséquences systémiques pour
nous et donc nous avons la nécessité de
bâtir ensemble un système qui est
électriquement robuste avec des
équilibres de nos voisins qui aillent
vers un équilibre entre intermittence et
commandable décarboné aussi et ça c'est
le point le plus important je pense des
10 15 ans qui viennent sans lequel nous
serons effectivement en difficulté
potentiellement à l'échelle européenne
pour des problèmes d'instabilité alors y
blunven et Franck
Montauger madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président Directeur Général de DF
d'abord merci pour votre mot
préliminaire sur ce qui s'est passé en
Bretagne je suis sénateur du morbillan
et on a
vécu des moments difficiles et quand on
a vu les colonnes de vos techniciens
arrivés dès le mardi on s'est dit que
tout ça était quand même bien organisé
bien icip en tout cas bravo pour pour ça
et surtout bravo pour le sens du service
public que vos agents ont développé sur
le terrain et puis comme tout le monde
on a un mot et une pensée pour votre
agent décédé à Pont àen dans le
Finistère moi je voulais vous poser deux
question une première question par
rapport au développement des énergies
renouvelables en pleine accélération sur
notre territoire et avec aujourd'hui un
goulet d'étranglement dans vos services
sur les contrats deedf obligation d'
chat on compte à peu près entre 9 et 12
mois de retard sur la signature de ces
contrats inutile de vous dire que ça
pose des problèmes de trésorerie pour
les porteurs de projets et des
conséquences financières non
négligeables voilà une réponse claire à
ce à cette question quel moyen
voulez-vous vous pensez-vous mettre en
œuvre pour raccourcir ces délais qui
deviennent insupportables sur le terrain
et le deuxième élément là c'est plus une
proposition on a vécu des moments très
difficiles notamment avec nos TPE sur
les petits commerçants sur les contrats
d'électricité n'est-il pas possible de
revoir vos contrats avec ces fameux
seuils de 36
kVA parce que un commerçant utilisant de
l'électricité c'est un élément essentiel
dans la vie de nos territoires
particulièrement de nos territoires
ruraux quand on a vu le nombre de ces
commerçants qui ont dû mettre la clé sur
la porte à cause de l'électricité le
seuil des 36 kVA est une chose mais
est-ce qu'il y aurait pas une
possibilité d'amender vos contrats pour
faire en sorte d'être en capacité à
répondre à leurs besoins sur le tarif
merci Franck
Montauger merci madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le Président pour votre
exposé je voudrais à mon tour avec un
peu d'émotion je vous le cache pas
rendre hommage à à Frédéric Despo euh
aussi teint comme moi dont la mort
illustre les les grandeurs et les
servitudes du service public de
l'énergie
jusqu'au tragique absolu en réalité
hélas j'ai une pensée particulière pour
son épouse et c'est trois enfants toute
sa famille et l'ensemble des collègues
d'énéis qui jusqu'à il y a peu étai
aussi mes collègues voilà donc je
voulais je voulais vous dire cela devant
la
commission monsieur le le
président à propos des des
investissements de de
points on parle on se focalise à juste
titre beaucoup sur les les moyens de
production on parle euh peu bien que
vous l'ayez évoqué des réseaux des
réseaux HTB des réseaux HTA de la
nécessité de les faire évoluer euh en
grande quantité pour pouvoir répondre à
l'évacuation de l'énergie sur l'ensemble
du territoire et par rapport à des zones
de production d'énergie qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui clairement identifiées en
réalité pour certaines d'entre elles oui
pour d'autres notamment renouvelabl
c'est c'est c'est moins évident euh est
est-ce que je suppose que vous avez
anticipé les difficultés de cet aspect
là des choses le volume d'investissement
réseau est considérable aussi c'est en
gros la moitié hein si j'ai enfin vous
vous direz quelle est la proportion
voilà donc je j'aurais voulu que vous
disiez quelque quelque chose là-dessus
par rapport à ce que vous avez dit des
des des
financements et de l'accès au
financement euh votre propos m'inquiète
beaucoup mais je suis peut-être pas sûr
de l'avoir bien compris est-ce qu'il
faut comprendre que vous mettez
explicitement l'État devant sa
responsabilité de mobiliser les marchés
financiers le le modèle économique
propre de DF vous l'avez dit ne le
permettant pas à lui seul voilà moi j'ai
compris que vous pliez l'État en
situation de responsabilité d'aller
chercher les financements que le modèle
lui-même ne produ pas peut-être ai-je
mal compris sur la question de
l'attractivité de l'entreprise par
rapport au au métiers à à développé quel
est monsieur le Président quelles sont
les grandes lignes du projet social qui
est le
vôre je suppose que vous le travaillez
ce projet social parce que tout va
ensemble avec les personnels et leurs
représentants et à for fiorie au sortir
d'une séquence gouvernementale
catastrophique qui s'est traduite par la
régression sociale qui est l'exension
l'extinction progressive du régime des
retraites des industries électriques et
gazières c'était un point d'attractivité
d'intérêt notamment pour les jeunes qui
était évident voilà dont on dont on se
prive c'est pas votre faute ça a été
voté et voulu comme ça mais je je
voudrais savoir donc pas en compensation
mais globalement quelles sont les
grandes lignes du projet social qui
participera de cette attractivité futur
est nécessaire de l'entreprise merci
Franck monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente euh monsieur le sénateur
merci de de pointer le sujet des d'abord
merci de votre témoignage pour pour
enedis merci à tous les deux
vraiment et puis pour notre notre
collègue décéd et sa famille
euh merci d'avoir pointé les obligations
d'achat c'est un sujet de préoccupation
majeure pour moi évidemment qui est en
grande partie li au fait que nous avons
une explosion de la demande puisque
quand on a un doublement de la base
installée d'une année sur l'autre par
définition nos capacités d'absorption de
la demande doivent s'adapter c'est c'est
pas juste 20 % 10 % de croissance c'est
d'une année sur l'autre on fait deux
fois ce qu'on avait l'année précédente
en base installée donc donc oui c'est
une explosion de la demande et nous
sommes en train de travailler avec nos
équipes pour accélérer tous les
processus le plus
possible du côté de nos clients
j'appelle à la plus grande anticipation
possible notamment quand ce sont des
professionnels parce que ça ça nous aide
bien sûr à planifier le travail et nous
revoyons évidemment nos systèmes
informatiques et l'ensemble de nos
procédures pour aller le plus vite
possible mais j'ai bien conscience de ce
sujet et croyez bien que nous sommes
mobilisé
pour pour revenir à un niveau de service
qui soit acceptable ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui c'est tout à fait clair sur
les le petit commerce évidemment comme
les PME le petit commerce a subit fin 22
début 23 une phase d'explosion des prix
très difficile à soutenir sur lequel le
gouvernement a pris des mesures
permettant d'amortir dans toute la
mesure du possible le choc que ça a
constitué pour pour ces entreprises ce
dispositif au passage étant le résultat
de la structure enfin évidemment de
l'explosion des prix associé à la guerre
en Ukraine mais également de la
structure constituée par de tiers
d'arèes le reste par essence limité au
marché spot donc beaucoup plus
vulnérable à une explosion des
prix pour les très petites
entreprises il y a des options possibles
dans le cadre de la discussion sur le
nouveau marché de l'électricité tel que
nous pouvons
l'envisager qui ne fasse plus de ce
seuil de 36 kVA qui est un seil
technique la limite du tarif par exemple
il y a des avantages et des
inconvénients pour ça je ne vais pas
vous dire c'est la solution on va y
aller il a des avantages des
inconvénients mais il y a des options
possibles pour pouvoir considérer les
TPE dans leur ensemble et pas uniquement
un sur technique à 36 kVA en tout cas ça
fait partie des discussions que nous
avons avec la Commission de régulation
de l'énergie et avec le
gouvernement Monsieur montoger Merci
beaucoup de de votre témoignage encore
une
fois il y a évidemment beaucoup beaucoup
de choses à faire sur la partie HTB HTA
c'est
clair nous avons une code part
d'investissement programme mais qui
évidemment fera fera l'objet des des
discussions ad hoc avec la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie sur sur le futur
plan d'enedis mais qui porte les
investissements d'enedis à un ordre de
grandeur de 5 milliards d'euros par an
ce qui est du jamais vu et et avec deux
objets principaux enfin peut-être trois
en tout cas les les deux objets les plus
coûteux sont le raccordement des
nouvelles capacités de production euh
puisque ce sont celles qui sollicitent
cite le plus avec un délai de
raccordement que l'on veut le plus court
possible et et ça concerne
essentiellement donc le renouvelable qui
soit renouvelable dit centralisé
c'est-à-dire des fermes solaires ou des
fermes éoliennes ou bien le renouvelable
décentralisé c'est-à-dire tous les
autoconsommateurs d'une certaine
puissance le deuxième pilier étant la
modernisation du réseau pour faire en
sorte que nous continuion d'enfouir nous
continuons de moderniser de rendre le
réseau plus résilient
face au changement climatiqu notamment
euh donc 5 milliards d'euros
d'investissement par an sur des
investissements du groupe qui sont euh
aujourd'hui entre 20 et 25 milliards
donc vous voyez que c'est de l'ordre du
quart des investissements du groupe un
peu moins un peu plus d'une année sur
l'autre c'est beaucoup et c'est
indispensable donc évidemment nous
allons continuer de nous focaliser sur
la capacité du réseau sur la résilience
et encore une fois ça ce n'est que
enedis euh sur euh votre point sur le
financement euh non je ne demande pas
RTE alors R je je je ne me prononce pas
sur RTE qui pour des raisons légales
d'ailleurs n'est pas dans le périmètre
de responsabilité du groupe Total
voilà et je pense que Xavier pi a dû
vous donner les
données ensuite sur votre question sur
le financement non je ne demande pas à
l'état de se substituer à
EDF simplement comme tout opérateur
électrique aujourd'hui nous avons besoin
d'éléments que seul une puissance
gouvernementale ou une puissance
publique peut donner pour fac
l'agrégation des financements qui sont
nécessaires par EDF pour réaliser ces
différents projets c'est pas la même
chose
ensuite voilà
ensuite sur l'attractivité de
l'entreprise je crois que
fondamentalement il faut commencer par
l'attractivité
métier c'est c'est l'élément le plus
fondamental de
l'attractivité et j'avais voilà j'avais
autant de mal à trouver des électriciens
ou ou des
électrotechniciens dans une entreprise
qui était industrielle que je pourrais
en avoir chez EDF si nous ne travaillons
pas à l'attractivité métiers donc
évidemment Derrien il faut offrir au
sein de l'entreprise les conditions
d'accueil les conditions de
développement de carrière les conditions
de formation les conditions de
d'apprentissage au fur et à mesure de la
carrière dans différents profils de
métier mais le premier élément c'est de
de nous assurer que dans on nous
attirons dans nos métiers euh et donc
pour cela nous avons deux initiatives
majeures qui sont en cours
si on prend les métiers fondamentaux du
groupe EDF qui
sont le métiers de la
production qui sont beaucoup des métiers
fondés
autour de la mécanique de la
thermodynamique des métiers de la de la
plomberie de la tuyauterie de la
chaudronerie et cetera qui sont pas que
le nucléaire mais autour de l'ensemble
des métiers qui permettent de
transformer une énergie en
électricité donc autour des de
l'Université des métiers du nucléaire
nous avons aujourd'hui de plus en plus
de lycées de collèges et d'universités
ingénieurs technicien qui rejoignent
cette université avec des accords que
nous passons territoire par territoire
pour faire en sorte que nous attirions
dans cette
filièrec nous le faisons avec notre
filière alors ça n'est pas les écoles de
métier de l'histoire mais c'est le même
esprit les écoles de métier de
l'histoire c'est les écoles de métiers
d'EDF uniquement pour EDF là il faut que
nous réussissions en filière donc nous
nous créons des écoles de métier de la
filière voilà ce que nous faisons nous
avons exactement la même chose et c'est
enedis d'ailleurs qui en est le pilote
pour le groupe sur les métiers de
l'électrotechnique puisque le deuxième
métier à parité finalement du groupe EDF
quand vous venez ramenez au métiers
fondamentaux c'est la capacité de gérer
HTA HTB basse tension l'ensemble des
éléments qui sont associés à
l'électrotechnique voilà les deux
métiers fondamentaux sur lesquels en
tant que tête de filiia dans les de cas
nous prenons la responsabilité d'animer
l'ensemble de la filière de formation
avec nos partenaires de l'éducation
nationale et l'ensemble des partenaires
des filièr métiers dans les deux
cas merci alors on va prendre les quatre
dernières questions pour quand même
libérer monsieur le Président Directeur
Général qui nous a consacré beaucoup de
temps donc Daniel salmon Lucien stanion
Christian Redon sarazi et Anne caerine
noisier soyez court merci madame la
Présidente je sal
ouis je vais essayer d'être très court
euh juste déjà je vais commencer
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
par du par du local nous avons un
certain nombre d'îles en Bretagne qui
sont qui ne sont pas connectés en
particulier l'île de Saint où il y a des
projets qui sont prêts depuis 10 20 ans
au moins une dizaine d'années et qui
sont bloqués à l'heure actuelle donc je
voudrais savoir comment vous envisagez
de lever ces ces points de blocage qui
me semble important parce que ce sont
vraiment des champs d'expérimentation
qui sont exceptionneles euh les
hydroliennes d'ailleurs notre dernière
hydrolienne ne significie plus
aujourd'hui de tarif de rachat donc ça
aussi c'est un c'est un souci et puis
après je vais aller carrément sur du sur
du sur du planétaire et sur la
souveraineté de de DF vous avez répondu
partiellement à à mon collègue Yannick
jado euh on a pas tout à fait les mêmes
les mêmes chiffres pour moi la totalité
de notre uranium de retraitement part en
Russie encore et la totalité de notre
uranium réenrichi revient de Russie euh
une bonne partie de notre
uranium enrichi on parlait d'un/ers mais
peut-être que ça a évolué provient
également euh de Russie notre uranium
naturel provient d'oubékistan et de
Kazakhstan avec plus ou moins euh la
mamise de Rosatom également sur euh
cela avec aujourd'hui les problématiques
du Niger euh où est euh notre
souveraineté et comment euh comptez-vous
la faire vivre merci
Lucien merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Directeur Général
je veux rester sur vraiment du très
local et très vite
et alors il y il y a les îles de mon
collègue et puis moi je suis dans le
vauluse un des plus beaux départements
et vous savez que on est très ensoleillé
et donc quel est quel est votre votre
point de vue sur la question de de
l'énergie renouvelable solaire et sur
notamment les questions de de stockage
de cette énergie et puis par ailleurs de
distribution en fonction de la saison
puisque il y a des moments où il y a
besoin de plus d'électricité que
d'autres moments moins d'ailleurs qui
correspondent pas aux saisons de
d'ensoleillement et donc quels sont vos
techniques là-dessus mais bon très vite
mais voilà merci beaucoup Chan et oui
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
directeur Président Directeur Général
moi je vais revenir sur un sujet très
Prati pratique aussi qui concerne ça a
été évoqué par le collègue les euh les
utilisateurs et notamment commerçants
artisans euh qui ont des contrats
supérieurs à 36 kVA euh et et qui dans
dans le cas auquel je pense ont dû faire
face à des factures de 21000 € puis
ensuite une annulation de facture de
15000 puis malgré tout une demande de
versement de 11000 € qui est totalement
impossible pour un boulanger en zone
rurale euh donc je vous demande pas de
solutionner le cas de de de cet artisan
mais on parle beaucoup de production
mais concernant les outils liés à la
commercialisation et à l'information des
des consommateurs que ce soit des des
des professionnels voir des particuliers
j'ai eu ces factures sous mes yeux c'est
totalement incompréhensible et et
eux-mêmes ne s'y retrouvent pas et et là
on est quasiment sur une situation de de
de de de de mise en difficulté avérée
d'un par sa facture EDF d'un artisan et
et en notamment parce que il y a une
incapacité totale à comprendre y compris
avec l'aide du correspondant DG FIP que
j'ai sollicité des interlocuteurs à Lyon
impossible d'avoir je dirais en en face
de au bout du fil une explication
intelligible donc est-ce que les outils
clients sont évoluont et aussi de leur
côté Anne Catherine merci Madame la
présente monsieur le Président Directeur
Général moi juste une petite demande
d'éclaircissement sur les impacts de
l'intermittence puisque en fait on on
comprend bien que le développement de la
production
ENR va se traduire par davantage de
modulation sur les unités pilotables et
donc sur les unités les centrale
nucléaire à venir donc dans quelle
mesure est-ce que ce cela impacte
éventuellement le le plan d' enfin le
rendement et le plan d'amortissement de
ces futur centrale nucléaire et puis
juste une petite
remarque suite à aux derniers événements
tempête pour vous dire Monsieur le
Président Directeur Général que il y a
aussi une réflexion à voir sur les les
réseaux numériques qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas prioritaires en matière
d'intervention et qui pourtant on le
sait sont d'importance vitale en matière
de de communication merci voilà monsieur
le Président Directeur Général pour ces
quatre dernières réponses et en vous
remerciant encore pour votre voilà votre
mobilisation et votre précision dans
l'ensemble des
réponses merci madame la Présidente
d'abord Merci à VOUS euh et je vois que
la passion de votre commission pour pour
les sujetses ne baisse pas et donc ça ne
fait que renforcer mon énergie donc
voilà sachez que c'est toujours un
plaisir de venir répondre à vos
questions
euh monsieur salmon alors je je connais
à peu près le enfin vraiment de loin le
projet de l'île- de sain j ai envoyé il
y a pas très
longtemps le dirigeant qui auprès de moi
suit toutes les énies parce que je
voulais effectivement comprendre où on
est était le projet quelles en étaient
les options donc il a été voir c'était
au mois d'octobre et donc il a il a
établi le contact et donc on va regarder
ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut faire pour
développer effectivement de mon
expérience les systèmes insulaires en
général ont finalement les contraintes
mais aussi l'opportunité de faire des
choses que qui n'émergent pas
spontanément sur sur un territoire
continental donc c'est aussi des
territoires d'innovation pour nous et
c'est bien comme ça qu'on le prend et il
me semble que effectivement les sénants
le souhaitent et sont motivés pour ça
euh alors comme l'île de sain est un/art
de la France selon la formule consacrée
on passe assez rapidement au Globe
effectivement euh donc euh donc
euh pour vous dire simplement ce que
j'ai répondu à Yannick jado tout à
l'heure nous ne sommes pas dépendant
nous ne sommes pas dépendants on a on
n'est pas dépendant de la Russie pour
notre fourniture oui il y a des
technologies sur lesquelles la Russie
est en pointe vous avez cité l'URT mais
pour autant nous nous ne dépendons pas
de cette filière pour notre propre
approvisionnement et et pour nos
ressources pour nos centrales euh quant
à l'oubékistan au Kazakhstan que vous
avez cité j accompagné le président de
la République la semaine dernière euh
voilà je peux vous confirmer que Orano a
des relations qui ne dépendent en rien
euh de de la Russie dans ces deux
territoires pour contribuer au
développement nos propres capacités
de donc minière et de et de et et de
ressources aano un un partenariat ancien
au Kazakhstan d'illeurs en matière
minière donc la meilleure façon
d'aborder sur le long terme ces
questions d'indépendance c'est
évidemment de continuer de diversifier
nos sources d'approvisionnement et c'est
évidemment la stratégie que nous
partageons avec Orano et sur laquelle
nous avons un soutien plein et entier
des pouvoirs
publics monsieur monsieur stanon on
pourrait y passer beaucoup de temps
parce qu'il y a plein de choses à dire
sur sur comment comment faire absorber
comment utiliser le solaire finalement
et notamment le solaire décentralisé
c'est celui que nos concitoyens peuvent
utiliser eux-mêmes bon le solaire a ses
caractéristique c'est que par définition
il produit quand il y a du soleil donc
ça marche pas la nuit et ça marche pas
quand il y a une couverture nuageuse
mais le reste du temps c'est une
production intéressante supplémentaire
sans coup variable donc elle est
intéressante bien sûr donc elle forme
capacité de stockage aussi elle forme et
donc c'est à ce point que je vaux venir
elle forme ce qu'on appelle le soleil
forme ce qu'on appelle une cloche le
monde électrique c'est-à-dire vous
regardez la production électrique du
jour vous voyez une cloche apparaître et
puis vous la voyez redescendre voilà
donc c'est la la fameuse cloche solaire
et quelque chose que vous voyez quand
vous êtes autoconsommateur vous la voyez
mais vous la voyez également sur la
production nationale donc avec de plus
en plus de capacité décentralisé qui
apparaisst cette cloche solaire prend
une une forme de plus en plus fréquente
notamment dans les périodes estivales et
donc au bout d'un moment ça finit par
poser des problèmes de
d'équilibrage qui ne peuvent être
seulement compensés par la modulation
des moyens production commandable et
donc c'est là que le stockage pour les
pays qui sont plus avancés que nous dans
le développement de cette cloche solaire
je pense à l'Australie ou à la
Californie elles ont ils ont
progressivement rendu quasi obligatoire
le stockage parce que c'est ce qui
permet d'élargir cette cloche et de
faire en sorte qu'elle ne soit pas
provocatrice finalement d'une
instabilité de réseau et donc nous
travaillerons dans le temps sur comment
faire en sorte que des moyens de
stockage et notamment le pilotage de la
recharge du véhicule électrique puisse
fin
correspondre à cette cloche solaire ou
comment d'autres moyens je pense
notamment à vos régions qui sont
ensoleillé donc peuvent être un peu
chaude l'été voilà mettre la
climatisation en face de la cloch
solaire c'est bien la mettre la nuit
c'est moins bien parce que plus vous
êtes capable de déplacer des charges
vers les moments où vous avez une
énergie abondante et s coup variable
plus c'est intéressant du point de vue
du
système et donc il faudra mais ça peut
inclure pour les alors pour les
autoconsommateurs ça ça ne ça ne compte
pas parce qu'il ne le voi pas c'est
c'est l'énergie qu'il consomme
directement et qui de toute façon qu'ils
auraient payé la nuit même moins cher
euh donc donc voilà un peu la boîte à
outils sur lequel il nous faut
travailler euh durablement euh enfin sur
les commerçants euh euh j'ai j'ai bien
conscience du problème euh effectivement
euh euh vous pouvez bien croire que la
totalité de nos nos collaborateurs qui
travaillent
en liaison avec la clientèle ont passé
un hiver 2022 2023 extrêmement tendu et
d'ailleurs je leur rends hommage parce
qu'ils étaient là pour répondre aux
clients parce que ces structures là une
partie dépend de def mais c'est une
petite partie le reste c'est un
empilement de beaucoup de choses qu'il
faut être capable d'expliquer à nos
clients et et je crois que
principalement l'un de nos enjeux dans
le Nouveau Monde électrique que nous
devons créer dans les mois qui viennent
pour au-delà de 2025 c'est aussi
d'arriver au au travers de
contractualisation qui sont plus stables
qui sont plus prévisibles de simplifier
les choses pour pour nos clients et plus
on met
destages dans une formation économique
d'un prix plus on arrive à des
situations compliquées pour les clients
donc la simplification fait partie de
nos
objectifs madame oui nous avons besoin
de simuler l'impact de la modulation sur
sur nos propres moyens de production
nous le faisons bien sûr dans dans
toutes nos prévisions nous simulons
l'impact de la modulation nécessaire
pour incorporer les éléments
intermittents dans le réseau au sein de
notre propre production ça reste à
l'horizon visible ça reste dans un
domaine gérable mais ça fait l'hypothèse
que nous travaillons notamment sur le
déplacement d'un certain nombre de
charge et sur le stockage dynamique donc
nous soyons capable également de rel
lancer l'investissement sur le stockage
et c'est une hypothèse
fondamentale sans cette hypothèse là
nous serions je pense à l'horizon 30
35 en terme de risque d'intermittence un
niveau assez élevé ces hypothèses sont
réalistes on est capable sur l'hydro sur
le stockage par batterie à l'échelle du
réseau de faire des progrès mais
également il nous faudra travailler sur
la capacité d'optimiser la charge des
véhicules parce que c'est l'élément qui
est le plus déterminant dans la capacité
d'absorption de l'in
voilà les éléments que nous avons et
enfin sur les réseaux numériques nous
sommes en je pense que vous vouliez
mentionner le le fait de maintenir la
puissance sur les réseaux numériques
c'est ça et nous sommes évidemment en
relation très étroite avec nos
partenaires gestionnair des réseaux
numériques pour faire en sorte que parmi
tous les clients de même que beaucoup
d'opérateurs d'infrastructure vitale
toutes les tous les établissements qui
accueillent des personnes en situation
de fragilité et cetera soit soit
absolument repéré dans les priorités de
de reconnexion quand on est dans des
situations comme
ça donc voilà comment nous essayons de
nous y atteler et bien encore une fois
merci au nom de l'ensemble de nos
collègues monsieur le Président
Directeur Général pour le temps que vous
nous avez consacré plus de 2 Hees
d'entretien d'audition et et de
questions variées et extrêmement
réactive merci avec la précision qui
vous caractérise on a déjà expérimenté à
nombreuses reprises et de nombreuses
mobilisations et moi je vois que quand
vous êtes venu dans le département des
ates maritimes vous avez aussi consacré
énormément de temps à la rencontre avec
l'ensemble des des acteurs qu'il soi
économiques sociaux et élus c'est
extrêmement appréciable et je pense
qu'on aura l'occasion de nouveau de
converser ensemble parce qu'il y a pour
l'année 2024 un certain nombre de
véhicules législatifs et d'enjeux qui
feront que nous devrons de nouveau voilà
vous questionner et avoir un petit peu
votre sentiment en tout cas merci merci
du fond du cœur et bonne journée à vous
toutes et à vous
merci madame la Présidente merci à
tous